A smart list of listeners that's Will, um, I just, uh, snuck in here, because I, I really wanted to connect with you guys, you know, just us, just one-on-one, just being honest, just sharing experiences, and really breaking down all these barriers, you know. Anyway, this has been great. All right, let's go with an all-new smart list. So, uh, listener, uh, Arnett's got his TV hair on right now. It looks incredibly handsome. They just snapped it in. You're, uh, you're on a lunch break. Is that right? Down there in Atlanta? Indeed. And what are you going to have for lunch today, aside from a great interview? You know, today for lunch, I think I'm having, it's a, uh, a salad. It's a Mediterranean salad.
一个聪明的听众列表，那是威尔，嗯，我只是，呃，溜进来的，因为我，我真的很想和你们联系，你知道，就我们，一对一，坦诚相待，分享经历，真正打破所有这些隔阂，你知道的。总之，这太棒了。好了，让我们开始一个全新的聪明列表。所以，呃，听众，呃，阿内特现在留着他的电视发型。看起来帅极了。他们刚给他弄好。你，呃，你正在午休。是这样吗？在亚特兰大那边？确实。除了精彩的采访，你今天午餐打算吃什么？你知道，今天午餐，我想我会吃，这是一个，呃，沙拉。这是一个地中海沙拉。
I've been eating these great, by the way, if there's anybody in, you're in the Atlanta area and looking for some food. My friend Brandy down here, she has a nice little business. She makes food for people. Someone just got a deal on their monthly expenditure. No, I'm already done. I'm already done. Speller last name. No, it just, it's, I think it's like, what's her website? She works in a lot of people and she, I gotta say, incredibly good, delicious. I'm already done. I've already fully paid so that I'm not getting anything out of it other than she's so good at what she does. And I really, and a person who works super hard and always delivers, I've been really impressed with it. Enough. You know what I noticed the other day too? I want to say this. You know, when you go online,
顺便说一下，我一直在吃这些很棒的食物，如果有人在亚特兰大地区，正在寻找一些食物。我在这边的朋友布兰迪，她有一个不错的小生意。她为人们做饭。有人刚在他们的月度支出上谈成了一笔交易。不，我已经做完了。我已经做完了。拼写姓氏。不，它只是，我想是，她的网站是什么？她为很多人工作，而且她，我不得不说，好得令人难以置信，美味。我已经做完了。我已经全额付款了，所以我除了她工作非常出色之外，什么也没得到。而且我真的，一个工作非常努力并且总是能交付成果的人，我对此印象非常深刻。够了。你知道我那天还注意到了什么吗？我想说这个。你知道，当你上网时，
sometimes you go on Twitter and you see people going, especially people who have the hashtag relatable. Did you just give a recommendation for a personal chef? If anyone's in ever in Atlanta. So relatable. Yeah. I'm just sorry. Sorry. To movie and TV stars. Sorry. That's what I meant to say. Any, any, any jet carriers you want to plug to? Jet edge. They're your favorite. You're the ones who turn me on to them. So you want to go down this road with me? No, no, I don't think so. So what I want to say is this, you know, you go on, you see these blue, verified check mark people and they complain about stuff and they, they, they, they, they, they tag like, you know, the company like, Hey, Coca-Cola, my, I opened up a Coke and it was
有时你会上推特，看到人们在发帖，特别是那些带有“相关”标签的人。你刚才是在推荐私人厨师吗？如果有人在亚特兰大。太相关了。是的。我很抱歉。抱歉。对电影和电视明星。抱歉。我就是想说这个。还有，还有，还有你想推荐的喷气式飞机运营商吗？Jet Edge。他们是你的最爱。是你们让我接触到他们的。所以你想和我走这条路吗？不，不，我不这么认为。所以我想说的是，你知道，你上网，看到这些蓝色认证勾选的人，他们抱怨事情，他们，他们，他们，他们，他们，他们标记，你知道，公司，比如，嘿，可口可乐，我的，我打开了一瓶可乐，它是
flat or like, Hey, Hertz, my car was at their, and they're doing it in a public way to complain because they want to get to the front of the line because they're real noisy, you know, squeaky wheels. And there aren't enough noisy bottom. I know, but I almost did. Well, bossy. I was going to say a bossy boss. Hey, keep scouting out of this. So, or a powerful shot. But you know what? Like the other day I was thinking, I traveled back and forth from here, from Atlanta to New York. Is the plane getting close to the run, to the, to the landing zone? Yeah. And I flew on Delta and I had weather delays both ways. And the people at Delta, airlines, can I tell you something? Everybody was amazing. The people who were working the
没气的，或者像，嘿，赫兹，我的车在他们那里，他们以公开的方式抱怨，因为他们想排到队伍的最前面，因为他们真的很吵，你知道，爱叫的轮子。而且没有足够的吵闹的底部。我知道，但我差点就做了。嗯，专横。我本来想说一个专横的老板。嘿，别再打听这个了。所以，或者一个强大的镜头。但你知道吗？就像那天我在想，我从这里，从亚特兰大往返纽约。飞机快到跑道，到，到降落区了吗？是的。我坐达美航空，往返都有天气延误。达美航空的人，我能告诉你一件事吗？每个人都很棒。那些在
gate, the people checking you in, the people on the plane, all the attendants, everybody was amazing. No, I feel like in that moment, I thought all these people, they get so much shit all the time. And every one of these people was so fucking good. And I want them to, and I thought like, they need to know that they were, they were doing a good job. I got no skin in this game other than to say they were really nice people. Somebody had a real nice Easter, I guess, huh? Yeah, I did. I had did with the kids and stuff. It was nice, but you know, Is this before or after you got in a huge fight with the flight attendants? Mm-hmm. Well, all I'm saying is look at the footage. I didn't start it.
登机口工作的人，那些为你办理登机手续的人，飞机上的人，所有的乘务员，每个人都很棒。不，我觉得在那一刻，我想这些人，他们一直受到这么多烂事。而这些人中的每一个都他妈的太好了。我希望他们，我想，他们需要知道他们做得很好。我在这件事上没有任何利益关系，只是想说他们真的是很好的人。有人度过了一个非常愉快的复活节，我想，是吗？是的，我度过了。我和孩子们在一起，之类的。这很好，但你知道，这是在你和空乘人员发生巨大争吵之前还是之后？嗯。好吧，我只是说看看录像。不是我先挑起的。
My mask was on. No, honestly, these people were so amazing. I just thought, why don't they just get some love? How about we just start going, hey, these people were great. I love that. I love that. Yeah. So that's it. Well, you're preaching the choir. You know, my mother was a flight attendant for Pan Am all those years. And they, they don't get their due. You know what, Jason? Somebody asked me about this today. True story. Did your mom and dad meet on a flight? True story? No, but they did meet. My dad and his buddy went to what they were told was a stewardess party there in New York. Yeah. They were like, well, let's go get laid. And they both found their wives there. Wow. Yeah.
我的口罩戴着。不，老实说，这些人太棒了。我只是想，为什么他们不能得到一些爱呢？我们为什么不开始说，嘿，这些人太棒了。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。是的，就是这样。好吧，你是在对牛弹琴。你知道，我母亲多年来一直是泛美航空的空乘人员。他们，他们没有得到应有的待遇。你知道吗，杰森？今天有人问我这件事。真实的故事。你父母是在飞机上认识的吗？真实的故事？不，但他们确实认识了。我父亲和他的朋友去了他们被告知是纽约的一个空姐派对。是的。他们当时想，好吧，让我们去搞定。结果他们都在那里找到了他们的妻子。哇。是的。
And it's just a party of stewardess or flight attendants, female flight attendants. In those days, it was stewardess Pan Am too, you know, with the, with the, that bowler hat and the little powder blue outfit. Wow. Pretty top level. Never knew that. I can't wait to interview you. It's going to be so exciting. Gang. Yeah. Today brings us a fella that I've been watching and studying and admiring for as long as I can remember. He is an incredible actor in both comedy and drama and is equally talented as a director in both genres as well. At just nine years old, he was immediately one to watch when he shot from the cannon on the short lived but much loved series Kate McShane, Sean, huh? And at 15, he doubled down with a shocking arc on the subversive yet
那只是一个空姐或飞行乘务员的派对，女性飞行乘务员。在那些日子里，那是泛美航空的空姐，你知道，戴着那个圆顶礼帽和那套浅蓝色的制服。哇。相当高水平。从来不知道这一点。我迫不及待地想采访你。这会非常令人兴奋。伙计们。是的。今天带来了一位我一直关注、研究和钦佩的家伙，只要我记得。他是一位在喜剧和戏剧方面都令人难以置信的演员，作为导演在两个领域同样才华横溢。仅仅九岁时，当他在短命但深受喜爱的系列剧《凯特·麦克沙恩》中像炮弹一样射出时，他就立刻成为了值得关注的人，肖恩，嗯？在15岁时，他在颠覆性但
sexy guiding light. What? After a brief and inspired take on adult films called The Hustler of Money, he found work at Saturday Night Live. Not seeing what he was looking for there, he went on to bring us some of our favorite characters in both television and film characters like Garth, Mother Loving, Kakapipu, Pew Pew, Silly Sammy, Gaylord, Chazz, Derek, Guitar Center Guy, and the deeply sensitive, intuitive, magical Tony Wonder. Please welcome Jerry and Ann's boy, Mr. Franklin Stiller. Oh my. Ben. Jesus. Oh, look. I like you pulled out the Kate McShane. Pretty good. Listen, Wikipedia really brings all the deep research when you eat it. And I didn't know your middle name was Franklin. What a hoot. No, my middle name is Edward Mira.
性感的《指路明灯》中以令人震惊的弧线加倍努力。什么？在一段名为《金钱骗子》的关于成人电影的简短而富有灵感的尝试后，他在《周六夜现场》找到了工作。在那里没有看到他想要的东西，他继续为我们带来了我们在电视和电影中一些最喜欢的角色，比如加斯、母亲爱人、Kakapipu、Pew Pew、傻萨米、盖洛德、查兹、德里克、吉他中心家伙，以及极其敏感、直觉敏锐、神奇的托尼·旺德。请欢迎杰瑞和安的儿子，富兰克林·斯蒂勒先生。哦，天哪。本。耶稣。哦，看。我喜欢你翻出了《凯特·麦克沙恩》。相当不错。听着，维基百科在你需要的时候确实带来了所有深入的研究。而且我不知道你的中间名是富兰克林。真是个笑话。不，我的中间名是爱德华·米拉。
I know, but wouldn't it be great if it was Franklin too? Benjamin Franklin Stiller. Coming out with a laugh. That's Jerry and Ann's work. First of all, I love the show, guys, and it's really fun to be here. Yeah, yeah. But I was listening to how it gets ramped up and I couldn't tell where it started. Yeah. So the chemistry feels, it feels very real. It's like a real thing. It's not something you guys put on for the show. No, you see, we just, we just connect. We just start rolling and there's no, there's no method to it. It's kind of amazing. It's your stupidity. But Will, why, Will, you look like you're doing a confessional for the bachelor.
我知道，但如果它也是富兰克林不是很好吗？本杰明·富兰克林·斯蒂勒。笑着出来。那是杰瑞和安的作品。首先，我喜欢这个节目，伙计们，能来到这里真的很有趣。是的，是的。但我一直在听它是如何被炒作起来的，我看不出它是从哪里开始的。是的。所以化学反应感觉，它感觉非常真实。这就像一件真实的事情。这不是你们为节目表演出来的东西。不，你看，我们只是，我们只是连接。我们只是开始滚动，没有，没有方法。这有点令人惊奇。这是你们的愚蠢。但威尔，为什么，威尔，你看起来像是在为《单身汉》做忏悔。
Or hold up a sign and say that you haven't been beaten. I'm in an office, I'm in an office, in a production office. You got good lighting there though. It's not bad. Really good lighting. Yeah. Ben, are you in Bruce Wayne's library or? I am in my, my room, my office at my house in New York in Westchester. Oh, wonderful. Yeah. It does have that kind of vibe. So you're still up there in Westchester, Ben? Yes. For, I guess like the last 12 or 13 years, we kind of go back and forth between New York City and Westchester. But yeah. It's nice. I feel like, I feel like Jason, like the last time that we had dinner or hung out was when we were moving from LA back to New York. And do you remember
或者举个牌子说你没有被打。我在办公室，我在办公室，在一个制作办公室。你那里的灯光不错。还不坏。真的很好的灯光。是的。本，你是在布鲁斯·韦恩的图书馆里吗？我是在我的，我的房间，我在纽约威彻斯特家里的办公室。哦，太棒了。是的。它确实有那种氛围。所以你还在威彻斯特，本？是的。我想过去12或13年，我们有点在纽约市和威彻斯特之间来回奔波。但是的。这很好。我觉得，我觉得杰森，就像我们上次吃晚饭或聚在一起的时候，是我们从洛杉矶搬回纽约的时候。你还记得
this? Walk me through it. But we had dinner. I forget who else was there. I don't remember much. Remind him of your name one more time too. That would be good. I think JJ Abrams was at the restaurant and came over and said, hello. That's what, that's what I remember. And then you said, I feel like you made a joke about like you're going, you're moving to New York, but you'll be back like in a year and a half or something. Do you remember that? I'm shocked that I don't remember that. Was I drinking still at the time? Shocked. I think we both were. No, I, at least 20 years ago. Yeah. No, but we have been, I've loved being in New York for the last time. I'm so jealous that you lived there. And you,
这个吗？带我走一遍。但我们吃了晚饭。我忘了还有谁在那里。我不记得太多了。再提醒他一次你的名字。那会很好。我想JJ·艾布拉姆斯在餐厅，走过来打了个招呼。这就是我记得的。然后你说，我觉得你开了一个玩笑，说你要搬到纽约，但你会在一年半左右回来之类的。你记得吗？我很震惊我不记得了。我当时还在喝酒吗？震惊。我想我们俩都是。不，我，至少20年前。是的。不，但我很喜欢最后一次在纽约。我很嫉妒你住在那里。而且你，
because I, the Westchester, first of all, I was born in Rye. So for some, I guess that's the reason I've got some sort of hankering to get back there, but. And you've stayed in Rye this whole time. You flipped the spelling, but you stayed right in it. I mean. Did you go to Rye Playland as a kid? So they say, I left when I was two, but I've been back there. I actually shot at, at, at Playland. We shot a, some of a film there. So it's still open. It's still happening. It's still open, but it's so pretty up in there. And where you guys are, it's just like. This is how Sean, you'd know Rye. This is where the New York Rangers practice facility is. Oh God. I think I have some photos. Yeah. I have some photos of me back there. Ben,
因为我，威彻斯特，首先，我出生在莱伊。所以出于某种原因，我想这就是我有一种回到那里的渴望的原因，但是。而且你一直待在莱伊。你改变了拼写，但你一直待在那里。我是说。你小时候去过莱伊游乐园吗？他们是这么说的，我两岁时离开了，但我回去过。我实际上在，在，在游乐园拍过戏。我们在那里拍了一些电影。所以它还在营业。它还在进行。它还在营业，但那里真的很漂亮。你们所在的地方，它就像。这就是肖恩，你会知道莱伊。这是纽约游骑兵队的练习设施所在的地方。哦，上帝。我想我有一些照片。是的。我有我回到那里的照片。本，
do you remember the last time we had dinner? Oh no. Say yes. I love that this is a circle of people who don't remember dinner. Do you remember it? No, I don't. We've never had it. It never happened. I know it never happened. Do you imagine, Ben, if you were like, yes, it was wonderful. Thank you for paying. Well, do you remember the last time we had lunch? I, I, wait, I do actually. What did it have been during a lunch break on a rest of development? No, it was at the Chateau and we were talking about Burt Wunderstone. Yeah. I, oh yes. Yeah. Wow. How about this? How about, I remembered and you didn't. Nobody can stop me for memory. Was it still there? I feel like he might have. Do you want to know? Wait,
你记得我们上次吃晚饭是什么时候吗？哦，不。说是的。我喜欢这是一个不记得晚饭的人的圈子。你记得吗？不，我不记得。我们从来没吃过。它从来没发生过。我知道它从来没发生过。你能想象吗，本，如果你当时说，是的，那太棒了。谢谢你付钱。好吧，你记得我们上次吃午饭是什么时候吗？我，我，等等，我确实记得。那是在《发展受阻》的午休时间吗？不，是在城堡酒店，我们在谈论伯特·旺德斯通。是的。我，哦，是的。是的。哇。这个怎么样？这个怎么样？我记得而你没记得。没人能阻止我的记忆。它还在那里吗？我觉得他可能。你想知道吗？等等，
sweet. For one second, Ben, that's one of my favorite comedies of all time, Burt Wunderstone. I think it's hysterical. This is Steve Carell as well. Yes. Yeah. Yes. And is Jim Carrey as well? No. I never saw it. You're confiding. Ben, we talked about it. Ben and I talked about it years ago when I was still on a rest of development. Yeah. And we talked about it. I think Stuart was there as Farrell calls an old red beard. And every morning we were on Blades of Glory, Ben, which you produced, as you know, with Stuart. And, and Farrell would walk up to, to Stuart and grab him by the beard and goes, it looks so real. Rest in peace, sweet still. Yeah. He was my producing partner for
甜心。等一下，本，那是我的最爱之一，伯特·旺德斯通。我觉得它歇斯底里。这也是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的。是的。而且也是吉姆·凯瑞吗？不。我从来没看过。你在吐露心声。本，我们谈过它。本和我几年前谈过它，当时我还在《发展受阻》。是的。我们谈过它。我想斯图尔特在那里，正如法瑞尔所说的老红胡子。每天早上我们在《冰刀双人组》时，本，正如你所知，你和斯图尔特一起制作的。而且，法瑞尔会走到斯图尔特面前，抓住他的胡子说，它看起来太真实了。安息吧，甜美的斯蒂尔。是的。他是我的制作合伙人，大约
about a long time. And he was an amazing guy. Love that. Yeah. Fascinating. Fascinating guy. So, Ben, now you've been, I feel like you have just gone down the directing hole. By the way, that's in a good way. You've just, it seems like you're, like you're just directing series and, and movies all the time. And it's like, you, are you ever going to emerge again as Ben Stiller, comedic, humongous comedic star? Ben, he gets on me about this too. Don't, don't, don't going to beat you up. I'm trying to crawl out of the directing hole. It's a deep hole, you know? No, I don't buy it. It's, I like it. I like being in the hole. I mean, I, I do enjoy it. Keep it cheap. And I try to, I try to not think about acting when I'm directing. I actually
很长一段时间。他是一个了不起的人。喜欢那个。是的。迷人。迷人的人。所以，本，现在你已经，我觉得你已经掉进了导演的洞里。顺便说一下，这是好事。你似乎，就像你一直在导演系列剧和电影。而且就像，你还会再次以本·斯蒂勒，喜剧，巨大的喜剧明星的身份出现吗？本，他也因为这个找我麻烦。别，别，别去打你。我正试图从导演的洞里爬出来。这是一个很深的洞，你知道吗？不，我不买账。它，我喜欢它。我喜欢在洞里。我是说，我，我确实很享受它。保持便宜。而且我尝试，我尝试在导演时不去想表演。我实际上
don't worry about it when I'm directing. I enjoy just directing because a lot of years I spent, you know, directing and acting, which you do, Jason, incredibly well. And I do remember another interchange we had a couple of years ago, maybe like three years ago. That's an accurate way of describing a spending time with Bateman. Interchange. Yeah. Yeah. An interchange we had about directing. It was the night you won, you won directing Emmy. Yes. Well deserved. And you were talking about directing and acting. And you said that you like it because you feel like it takes out the middleman. That, yeah. And it's one less actor. You've got to have a, this sometimes delicate, creative negotiation with. Yeah. You're kind of making it sound easy. I think it's not
导演时不用担心它。我喜欢只是导演，因为我花了很多年，你知道，导演和表演，你做得非常好，杰森。我确实记得我们几年前，也许三年前，有过另一次交流。这是一个描述与贝特曼共度时光的准确方式。交流。是的。是的。我们关于导演的交流。那是你赢得导演艾美奖的那天晚上。是的。当之无愧。你在谈论导演和表演。你说你喜欢它，因为你觉得它省去了中间人。那，是的。而且少了一个演员。你必须有一个，有时是微妙的，创造性的谈判。是的。你听起来让它变得很容易。我觉得它不是
that easy. And I feel like you're able to do it very well. But Ben, I would say, I would say this though, Ben, for, as Jason said, it cuts out that long conversation. And Jason, in your case, it cuts out, if you've ever acted with Jason, it cuts out the 30 minutes of questions from Jason. He's his own worst, you know, director or actor. Is it fun watching me ask myself questions though? Because what I do is I, I switch over to the other side and I answer it and then I can. What he likes to do is go like, well, this is a really simple situation. There must be a complicated reason for why it's like this. But Ben, do you like to watch the playback of yourself? Do you do that? Because I worked with a director, actor once a long time ago, who loved to watch
那么容易。而且我觉得你能够做得很好。但本，我会说，我会说这个，本，正如杰森所说，它省去了那段冗长的对话。而且杰森，在你的情况下，它省去了，如果你曾经和杰森演过戏，它省去了杰森的30分钟问题。他是他自己最糟糕的，你知道，导演或演员。看着我问自己问题很有趣吗？因为我做的是我切换到另一边，我回答它，然后我可以。他喜欢做的是像，好吧，这是一个非常简单的情况。一定有一个复杂的原因，为什么它是这样的。但本，你喜欢看你自己的回放吗？你做那个吗？因为我很久以前和一个导演、演员一起工作过，他喜欢看
himself in, you know, in playback. And we would just watch him watch himself and laugh at himself. Yeah, no, that's, I'd love three guesses at that. No, I won't do that. But, but don't you, I mean, I've been trying to do what you do from an acting standpoint, my whole career, and that, that is basically this great proxy for the audience. You are the audience. You are the every man. You are the straight man. You are the person the camera needs to cut to after something outrageous has happened or something dramatic has happened or something. So don't you find that when you were acting and directing, that you had this great sort of ease that you knew that the sort of the grounding element was taken care of, that you didn't have to worry
他自己，你知道，在回放中。我们只是看着他看自己，嘲笑自己。是的，不，那，我想要三个猜测。不，我不会那样做。但，但你不，我是说，我一直在尝试从表演的角度做你所做的事情，我的整个职业生涯，那就是基本上是观众的伟大代理人。你是观众。你是普通人。你是直男。你是当一些离谱的事情发生或一些戏剧性的事情发生或一些事情发生后，摄像机需要切入的人。所以你不觉得当你表演和导演时，你有一种伟大的轻松感，你知道那种基础元素被照顾到了，你不需要担心
that there was going to be this person at the center that is normal so you could take these bigger swings comedically around with the other characters and stuff? Sometimes I felt like that. I mean, I did feel like once it came around to having to do my stuff, I kind of had a sense of what I wanted to do. But I also felt a lot of the time, and maybe it's because I did it over a number of years and sort of got to the point where I just, it felt like a lot of work to then have to jump, like set up the shot and then jump in front of the camera. And then you have to act, then you have to do it. And I felt like that was harder to do than you, I felt like I couldn't concentrate on both. And the first day that I started on Escape at Dan, or the first, which is
会有这个处于中心的人是正常的，所以你可以在其他角色周围进行更大的喜剧尝试之类的？有时我觉得那样。我是说，我确实觉得一旦轮到我必须做我的事情时，我有一种我知道我想做什么的感觉。但我同时也觉得很多时候，也许是因为我做了很多年，并且到了那种觉得必须跳，比如设置镜头然后跳到摄像机前感觉像很多工作。然后你必须表演，然后你必须做它。我觉得那比你更难做，我觉得我无法同时集中注意力。我在《丹尼莫拉越狱》开始的第一天，或者第一，这是
like the first thing I directed, I didn't act in, the first day I was so happy. I was so relieved. Like to set up a shot and then not have to jump in front and sort of care what, you know, like my hair was and all that stuff. But what isn't acting, acting seems as comfortable for you as it is for me. I'm not saying it's easy, but it seems comfortable enough for you where it wasn't that much of an effort to act. And instead, it was actually, here's somebody who's in front of the camera that is mindful of all the other technical things that are going on that you can actually help by how you are acting or by hitting that mark or not shadowing that person. Or did you find that it was nice to have a soldier there that was taking care of all this stuff for you?
像我导演的第一件事，我没有演，第一天我太高兴了。我太如释重负了。就像设置一个镜头然后不必跳到前面，并且关心，你知道，我的头发是什么之类的东西。但什么不是表演，表演对你来说似乎和对我来说一样舒服。我不是说它很容易，但它对你来说似乎足够舒服，以至于它不是那么大的努力去表演。相反，它实际上是，这里有一个在摄像机前的人，他注意到了所有其他正在进行的技术事情，你可以通过你的表演方式或者通过击中那个标记或者不遮挡那个人来提供帮助。或者你发现有一个士兵在那里照顾所有这些事情对你来说很好吗？
A soldier in myself, you mean? Yeah, exactly. Yeah, somebody that's making it all kind of come together. Yeah, but I never really, I never really thought about it that way because I felt like, okay, that's just part of everything that's going on. You know, I mean, what do you think, though, when you're doing it and you're guys, we're going to be with you in one second. You know what, this is fascinating because this is much more, I'm waiting for somebody to start snoring. It's much more of a deep dive into how Jason works than you at every moment. And what's great is that his sort of, his acting ambition is to just provide a blank slate for the audience, for the editors to cut to. I mean, what an artistic objective to have. Fucking great.
一个士兵在我自己身上，你是这个意思吗？是的，完全正确。是的，有人让这一切融合在一起。是的，但我从来没有真正，我从来没有真正那样想过，因为我觉得，好吧，那只是正在发生的一切的一部分。你知道，我是说，你觉得呢，当你做它的时候，你们，伙计们，我们一秒钟就会和你们在一起。你知道吗，这很迷人，因为这比，我正在等某人开始打呼噜。这比你每一刻都更深入地了解杰森是如何工作的。而且伟大的是，他那种，他的表演野心只是为观众，为编辑切入提供一张白纸。我是说，多么艺术的目标。他妈的太棒了。
I just want to give, I want to give them something, just a cut point. Somebody's not blocked the light. His name has become cut point, which is great. You'd think that he'd be insulted by it. Now, Ben, all right, so there's no action. Wait, I'm just going to say this just kind of to what you were saying, Jason, which is, I don't know if it's entirely true. You have played characters who have been at the center of a bunch of insane situations and who are sort of put upon, but you've also, your bread and butter has also been playing characters who are completely on hinged or completely out there. You've actually moved quite seamlessly between the two. And I wonder, I actually have always wondered, like, which do you like playing? Just a bunch of characters
我只是想给，我想给他们一些东西，只是一个切入点。某人没有挡住光。他的名字已经变成了切入点，这很棒。你会认为他会因此受到侮辱。现在，本，好吧，所以没有动作。等等，我只是要说这个，有点像你刚才说的，杰森，我不确定它是否完全正确。你扮演过处于一堆疯狂情况中心的角色，并且有点被强加于人，但你也，你的主要收入来源也是扮演完全脱节或完全出格的角色。你实际上在两者之间切换得相当无缝。而且我好奇，我实际上一直很好奇，比如，你喜欢扮演哪一个？一堆角色
are going through my head right now. I know, same here. Between unhinged and blank slate, yeah. Between unhinged and blank slate. What would you rather do? Because the robot loves big blank slate. Go ahead. I enjoy, I mean, honestly, it's been a few years. I never thought I'd go this long in my life without acting really. It's been like five or six years. And I never as a, just as an actor over the years thought, oh, I take that much time off. And I think when I look back at it, I enjoyed, I enjoyed all of it, enjoyed the different, you know, some of those broader characters were, you know, tonally things that are just so like over the top that I felt like it was like more fun to do that kind of thing. But then I'd also enjoy being in somebody else's movie
现在正在我的脑海中闪过。我知道，我也是。在脱节和白纸之间，是的。在脱节和白纸之间。你宁愿做什么？因为机器人喜欢大的白纸。继续。我享受，我是说，老实说，已经几年了。我从来没想过我这辈子会这么久不演戏。已经有五六年了。而且我从来没有作为一个，只是作为一个演员多年来想，哦，我休那么长时间。而且我觉得当我回顾它时，我享受，我享受这一切，享受不同的，你知道，那些更广泛的角色是，你知道，音调上非常夸张的事情，我觉得做那种事情更有趣。但我也喜欢在别人的电影里
where I could just be, you know, a real human being and try to also like kind of maybe not have to worry about really maybe not be as self aware about what I was doing. Right. Yeah. Do you know what I mean? Do you ever get like, like, we are all four of us, we all produce stuff as well, right? And I find myself when I'm when I'm producing something and an actor has an issue or wants to discuss, I'm like, God, I don't want to fucking deal with that. They're crazy actors are fucking crazy. And then I'm an actor in something and I turn into a crazy person. Like, do you feel that way when you direct? Are you like, I know how to deal with this kind of situation or this pathos of this human being because I've been there. It's a shorthand. Yeah, I mean, I think
我可以只是，你知道，一个真实的人，并尝试也像有点也许不必担心真的也许不必像我对我在做什么那样自我意识。对。是的。你知道我的意思吗？你有没有像，像，我们四个人，我们也制作东西，对吧？而且我发现当我在制作某样东西时，一个演员有问题或想讨论，我就想，上帝，我不想他妈的处理那个。他们是疯狂的演员，他妈的疯狂。然后我是一个演员，我变成了一个疯狂的人。像，当你导演时你觉得那样吗？你是不是像，我知道如何处理这种情况或这个人的痛苦，因为我经历过。这是一种速记。是的，我是说，我觉得
that's what, yeah, what Jason is saying, like, you don't have to worry about that with yourself, you know, that you can just kind of do your thing. But Jason, you have to deal with this. And when you're directing and acting with other actors, how, you know, every actor has their own thing has their own point of view where they're coming from. And you have to figure out how to connect with them. And sometimes when you're acting in a scene with them, and you have to also give them something or try to give them some direction, that can be, I mean, I imagine on the show, since you've worked with the same actress for a long time, you guys have a sort of a shorthand. Yeah, yeah, but then you but then there's also there's the day players as well,
这就是，是的，杰森所说的，就像，你不必担心你自己，你知道，你可以只是做你的事情。但杰森，你必须处理这个。而且当你导演并与其他演员演戏时，如何，你知道，每个演员都有自己的事情，有自己的观点，他们从哪里来。而且你必须弄清楚如何与他们联系。而且有时当你和他们演戏时，你还必须给他们一些东西或尝试给他们一些指导，那可能是，我是说，我想在节目中，因为你和同一个女演员工作了很长时间，你们有一种速记。是的，是的，但然后你，但然后还有临时演员，
that you don't have that history with or any other project where, yeah, it's, you know, there's there's a different thing you need to do as a director, as opposed to an actor, for sure, with with respect to making sure people are comfortable. But there's also that thing, I mean, I don't know, Ben, I don't know how much of the stuff that you directed, you also wrote, I did a short lived series, two seasons called flake that we did on Netflix, a little small applause, please. No, no, no, there's no applause to be had, but it was like it was an experimentation. It was an experiment and I don't know, but we it was great. Well, having written it, thank you. But I wrote it and then and then show ran it and acted it and then
你没有那种历史，或者任何其他项目，是的，这是，你知道，作为导演，你需要做的事情与演员不同，当然，关于确保人们感到舒适。但还有那件事，我是说，我不知道，本，我不知道你导演的东西有多少也是你写的，我做了一个短命的系列剧，两季，叫《薄片》，我们在Netflix上做的，一点小小的掌声，请。不，不，不，没有掌声，但它就像它是一个实验。这是一个实验，我不知道，但我们，它很棒。好吧，写了它，谢谢。但我写了它，然后，然后担任制片人并演了它，然后
second season directed. So I'd be in the scene with another actor and great. I loved everybody who we had on the show and they were great. However, however, having written the scene. And so then I've already got it coming from that and then show and then thing and then thinking about, well, we're never going to use this. And you know, so I was constantly in that and I found it very difficult. Sometimes the last thing on the list was acting in the scene. So I and I felt like that was the thing that was like, I should be paying more attention to the acting in the scene, but I'm thinking about all these other things first. Yeah. And ironically, that's the most important thing. Yeah. At the end of the day, you know, that's what I would feel
第二季导演了。所以我会在场景中和另一个演员在一起，太棒了。我喜欢我们在节目中的每个人，他们都很棒。然而，然而，写了那个场景。所以然后我已经从那里得到了它，然后制片人，然后事情，然后思考，好吧，我们永远不会使用这个。而且你知道，所以我一直在那个里面，我发现它非常困难。有时列表上的最后一件事是在场景中表演。所以我，我觉得那是像，我应该更关注场景中的表演，但我首先在想所有这些其他事情。是的。而且讽刺的是，这是最重要的事情。是的。归根结底，你知道，那就是我会觉得
like. Okay. At the end of the day, I have to make sure that I'm in present in the scene and somehow connecting and you know, that's well, like I was going to say, so so Tropic Thunder, for instance, who you wrote with our whole of her applause, massive applause. Justin Thoreau, who's not a listener of the show. So we can mention, you know, I heard the Justin episode that you guys did. Sorry about that. And talk about a guy who gets down to it. And you guys wrote it, wrote together and he got down into it. And if he had sleeves, he would have rolled them up. And but you guys, you guys, he owns no sleeves. He owns no sleeves. Didn't you almost buy him a box of sleeves for Christmas? I did. I did for Christmas. And I was going to buy him. Yeah, Ben,
像。好吧。归根结底，我必须确保我在场景中，并且以某种方式连接，你知道，那是，好吧，就像我要说的，所以《热带惊雷》，例如，你和我们的整个掌声，巨大的掌声一起写的。贾斯汀·塞洛克斯，他不是节目的听众。所以我们可以提到，你知道，我听了你们做的贾斯汀那一集。对此感到抱歉。而且谈论一个真正投入其中的家伙。你们写了它，一起写了它，他投入其中。如果他有袖子，他会卷起来。而且，但你们，你们，他没有袖子。他没有袖子。你不是差点给他买了一盒袖子作为圣诞礼物吗？我买了。我买了作为圣诞礼物。而且我打算给他买。是的，本，
I was going to buy him a box of sleeves. But if you had such veiny biceps, come on, would you have that's true? Yeah, that's true. At 50. I mean, the guy, he's gorgeous. He sent us a photo yesterday to Jason and me from the, from the, um, the jungle of Mexico. He's wearing a hat and he said, I'm jonesing for adventure. And then you sort of see the whole phone. He said, Indiana jonesing. And I was like, Hey, buddy, didn't know there was a Nick Fouquet hat store down in the jungle. But anyway, my point is, my point is this, you write Tropic Thunder and then you're in the scene. Do you have those moments when you're in a scene as the writer where you're going, huh, this is going differently than I thought. Yeah. I mean, I think it just comes down to when you're
我打算给他买一盒袖子。但如果你有那么有静脉的二头肌，来吧，你会那样吗？那是真的。是的，那是真的。在50岁时。我是说，这家伙，他太美了。他昨天给我们发了一张照片，给杰森和我，从，从，嗯，墨西哥的丛林。他戴着帽子，他说，我渴望冒险。然后你有点看到整个手机。他说，印第安纳·琼斯。然后我就像，嘿，伙计，不知道丛林里有一家尼克·福凯帽子店。但总之，我的意思是，我的意思是这个，你写了《热带惊雷》，然后你在场景中。当你作为编剧在场景中时，你有那些时刻，你会想，嗯，这和我预想的不一样。是的。我是说，我觉得它只是归结为当你
doing the scene, what's going to make the scene work? Does it feel like it's working, you know, and it becomes its own thing. And I think that's no matter what, even if you are the writer and you're not in it, you have to let go of your idea of what the scene, you think the scene was or what you wrote and just look at what's happening in front of you as a director and then figure out how to find the life in it in the moment, which is, I think that's just directing. Can I ask you something? First of all, Ben, I have to say, you were one of those actors that I've always looked up to my whole life and one of those people, you know, we all have those kind of inspirational, especially in comedy. And I was like, Oh my God, I would kill to have Ben Stiller's career. He seems
做场景时，什么会让场景工作？它感觉它在工作吗，你知道，它变成了它自己的东西。而且我觉得无论如何，即使你是编剧而你不在里面，你也必须放手你对场景的想法，你认为场景是什么或者你写了什么，只是作为导演看看你面前正在发生什么，然后弄清楚如何找到那一刻的生命，这，我觉得那只是导演。我能问你一件事吗？首先，本，我必须说，你是那些我一生中一直仰望的演员之一，那些人之一，你知道，我们都有那种灵感，特别是在喜剧方面。而且我就像，哦，天哪，我愿意为了拥有本·斯蒂勒的职业生涯而杀人。他看起来
like such a great guy. He's super talented. You actually said I'd kill Ben to have his career. That's what you said. What was the actual quote? And then going on to directing and I was like, wow, that's just so cool. I'm getting to my favorite show of all, one of my favorite shows of all time now is Severance. I don't know if anybody's seen it. Of course. It's incredible. It's amazing. I don't know if you know, I'm going to play with one of your lead actors now. Tramel Tillman, right? Yeah. Tramel Tillman. Yeah. He's amazing. Incredible. Don't say anything about that. I haven't finished it yet. Oh, okay. But can you please just as a huge, huge fan of you and that show, tell me the genesis of how that came about and it's without ruining the ending.
像一个这么好的人。他超级有才华。你实际上说我愿意为了拥有他的职业生涯而杀本。那是你说的。实际的引语是什么？然后继续导演，我就像，哇，那太酷了。我现在要进入我最喜欢的节目，我最喜欢的节目之一，现在是《人生切割术》。我不知道有没有人看过。当然。它令人难以置信。它太棒了。我不知道你知不知道，我现在要和你的一个主演一起演戏。特拉梅尔·蒂尔曼，对吧？是的。特拉梅尔·蒂尔曼。是的。他太棒了。令人难以置信。别说关于那个的任何事情。我还没看完。哦，好吧。但你能请，作为一个你和那个节目的超级，超级粉丝，告诉我它是如何产生的起源，而且是在不破坏结局的情况下。
So, you know, in the finale went, no, it's incredible. By the way, that finale is amazing. No, the it's a great show business story. The writer, Dan Erickson, had been trying to get something produced as a writer for a while and he sent the script to our production company. This is five plus years ago. He sent as a writing sample and Jackie Cohn, who's the creative executive of our company, gave it to Nikki Winesack, who is working with the company and we read it and was like, this is great. It's a great writing sample. But I was like, this would be a great show. And so we just got it set up at Apple. They were the only people who wanted to develop it. You know, you have a piece of material, you take it around town, you pitch it and you see who wants
所以，你知道，在结局中，不，它令人难以置信。顺便说一下，那个结局太棒了。不，这是一个伟大的商业故事。编剧，丹·埃里克森，作为编剧已经尝试生产一些东西有一段时间了，他把剧本寄给了我们的制作公司。这是五年多前的事了。他寄了一个写作样本，杰基·科恩，我们公司的创意主管，把它给了尼基·温萨克，他在公司工作，我们读了它，觉得，这太棒了。这是一个伟大的写作样本。但我当时想，这将是一个伟大的节目。所以我们只是在苹果公司把它设置好了。他们是唯一想开发它的人。你知道，你有一件材料，你把它带到城里，你推销它，看看谁想
to do it. And I find that a lot of the time, like usually just one or two places that want to do something, right? They were the ones who wanted to do it. They were just starting up. They didn't really exist yet. And Christopher Walken, John Totoro, Patricia Arquette, Adam Scott, I mean, it's the cast is a Tramel Tillman cast is amazing. I didn't know Chris Walken was in it yet because I'm only going to fucking go. I'm going to kill you. Help, help, help. You're one episode in. No, I'm three episodes in. That's incredible. That's incredible. It's such a great show. We will be right back. And now back to the show. When you look at something as precise as what Severance is as far as filmmaking goes, who is that inside you? Where did that guy
做它。而且我发现很多时候，就像通常只有一两个地方想做某事，对吧？他们是想做它的人。他们才刚刚开始。他们实际上还不存在。而且克里斯托弗·沃肯，约翰·托托罗，帕特里夏·阿奎特，亚当·斯科特，我是说，演员阵容是特拉梅尔·蒂尔曼演员阵容太棒了。我不知道克里斯·沃肯已经在里面了，因为我只是他妈的要走。我要杀了你。救命，救命，救命。你才看了一集。不，我看了三集。那太令人难以置信了。那太令人难以置信了。这是一个伟大的节目。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。当你看着像《人生切割术》这样精确的东西，就电影制作而言，那是你内心的谁？那个人是从哪里
grow from somebody who was a child of two incredible comedy stars who and you coming up in sort of sketch world and then pure comedy world and then maybe some dramatic work. And like, how did that muscle sort of develop in you where it was like you're such an incredible filmmaker, the precision and the focus to detail and camera work and sound and lighting and all of this stuff. Where did that? How did that develop? I mean, I feel like it's always been a part of what I love since I was a kid. And I don't know. I'm curious. I'm not just throwing this back to you, Jason, but since you do this, like you always have you always loved directing? I have. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Since you were a kid. But did it come like I did where it was just from watching people around on the set?
成长起来的，从一个两个伟大的喜剧明星的孩子，你以某种素描世界出现，然后是纯喜剧世界，然后也许是一些戏剧作品。而且像，那块肌肉是如何在你身上发展的，以至于你是一个如此伟大的电影制作人，精确度和对细节的关注，摄像机工作和声音和灯光以及所有这些东西。那是在哪里？它是如何发展的？我是说，我觉得它一直是我从小就喜欢的一部分。而且我不知道。我很好奇。我不是只是把这个扔回给你，杰森，但既然你做这个，就像你一直，你一直喜欢导演吗？我有。是的。是的。对。从你小时候起。但它像我一样，只是从看着片场的人而来吗？
Like, oh my God, look how you make fake life. It's like I became fascinated with what a crew does. Like the cast and stuff acting and all that stuff. Yeah. Yeah. It was like, but that was familiar to me. But seeing how people created like, oh, this is how you put make an audience a little bit scared. You put the camera on your shoulder and you like all these little tricks and I love that. I loved all of the nuts and bolts of filmmaking as a kid. I would get American cinematographer. You mentioned Kate McShane, my early credit. That was my mother's show. My mother had a series on CBS, an hour drama where she played an Irish lawyer who solve cases every week and only lasted for half a season. But I remember going on the set of that at Paramount Studios and I played Susan
就像，哦，天哪，看你是如何制造虚假生活的。就像我开始对剧组做什么着迷。像演员之类的表演和所有那些东西。是的。是的。它就像，但这对我来说很熟悉。但看到人们如何创造，像，哦，这就是你如何制作让观众有点害怕。你把摄像机放在你的肩膀上，你像所有这些小技巧，我喜欢那个。我喜欢小时候电影制作的所有螺母和螺栓。我会得到美国电影摄影师。你提到了《凯特·麦克沙恩》，我早期的信用。那是我的母亲的节目。我母亲在哥伦比亚广播公司有一个系列剧，一个小时的戏剧，她扮演一个爱尔兰律师，每周解决案件，只持续了半个赛季。但我记得去派拉蒙工作室的那个片场，我扮演苏珊
Strasberg's son who was Lee Strasberg's daughter. No way. Yeah. And I had one scene. I was nine years old and I remember I was waiting around a corner on the set. I remember how the set smelled, how the fresh paint and the lights and there was a cue light for me. That was when the light, when the red light, yeah, when the red light went off, then I would go in and I just remember thinking, oh, that is so cool. And I was just fascinated with all of it and his special effects makeup and, you know, just the process. So it was always, you know, I was obsessed with all those Planet of the Apes movies and Beside an Adventure and all that. So actually the outside part of it, sort of the mechanics of it was more interesting to me at first than the actual telling of stories
斯特拉斯伯格的儿子，他是李·斯特拉斯伯格的女儿。没门。是的。而且我有一个场景。我九岁，我记得我在片场的角落里等着。我记得片场闻起来怎么样，新鲜的油漆和灯光，而且有一个提示灯给我。那是当灯，当红灯，是的，当红灯熄灭时，然后我会进去，我只是记得想，哦，那太酷了。而且我只是对这一切着迷，他的特效化妆和，你知道，只是过程。所以它一直，你知道，我痴迷于所有那些《人猿星球》电影和《冒险》以及所有这些。所以实际上它的外部部分，某种机制对我来说起初比实际讲述故事更有趣
or expressing some sort of, you know, emotion. It was more about that stuff. And for a while, I thought I wanted to be a cinematographer when I was a kid. But both of you guys had very, so if you think about it, you explained, you guys had very, not the same trajectory, but you had very, there was similar that you're both young. Jason told the story recently how the first time when he lost his virginity, he had a cue light. Isn't that right, Jason? Yeah. And I said, can we just hold the cue just a little bit longer for me? And they kept telling him, you jumped your cue, you jumped your cue. Yeah. But that was... The light was starting flashing. Pre-mature cue light, huh? Yeah. But I mean, both your parents were, of course, your mom and dad,
或表达某种，你知道，情感。它更多是关于那些东西。而且有一段时间，我小时候想成为一名电影摄影师。但你们俩都有非常，所以如果你想一想，你解释了，你们俩有非常，不是同样的轨迹，但你们有非常，有相似之处，你们俩都很年轻。杰森最近讲了一个故事，关于他第一次失去童贞时，他有一个提示灯。不是这样吗，杰森？是的。我说，我们能为我再多保持一点提示吗？他们一直告诉他，你跳过了你的提示，你跳过了你的提示。是的。但这那是……灯开始闪烁。过早的提示灯，是吗？是的。但我是说，你们俩的父母当然，你的妈妈和爸爸，
your mom, who I had the pleasure of knowing a little bit and I did that movie with her years ago, Southie, with the great Anne Mira and lovely lady and was always so kind and sweet whenever I interact with her. And then your dad, of course, was just the great Jerry Stiller. I mean, you grew up with these, you know, these people, these... You grew up in a comedy environment and to Jason's point, in the cinema. And Jason, your dad was a director and a writer and your sister was an actor and is an actor. And you guys both grew up in it. Was there any other way for you to go but to both become directors? I don't think so. Yeah. Or just staying in this business. I mean, I would have been screwed, you know, if I was forced to do anything else.
你的妈妈，我有幸认识一点，而且我多年前和她拍了那部电影，《南边》，和伟大的安·米拉和可爱的女士，无论我什么时候和她互动，总是那么善良和甜蜜。然后你的爸爸，当然，只是伟大的杰瑞·斯蒂勒。我是说，你和这些人一起长大，这些……你在喜剧环境中长大，按照杰森的观点，在电影院。而且杰森，你的爸爸是导演和编剧，你的妹妹是演员，也是演员。你们俩都在里面长大。除了都成为导演，还有别的路可以走吗？我不这么认为。是的。或者只是待在这个行业。我是说，如果我被迫做任何其他事情，我会搞砸的，你知道。
I never thought about doing anything else, you know, for better or for worse. Did you go to college? Did you get a degree in anything else? No. I went to UCLA for nine months and then I quit. I went to the acting drama department because I wanted to go to the film making department, but they didn't have, it didn't start till junior year back then. And so, and I couldn't get into USC film school, you know, and not great grades. So I went to UCLA, which, you know, good enough grades to go there. Harder to get into UCLA now. Yeah. Yeah. And I... Is that true? Yeah. I did not do well there. I just sort of didn't assimilate and I kind of just was like, well, I wanted to be doing it. So I quit and came back to New York. So then did you feel a pressure just to
我从来没想过要做别的事，你知道，不管好坏。你上大学了吗？你拿了其他专业的学位吗？没有。我在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）待了九个月就退学了。我进了戏剧系，因为我想去电影制作系，但那时候他们没有那个系，要到大三才开始。所以，我没能进南加州大学（USC）的电影学院，你知道，成绩不太好。所以我去了加州大学洛杉矶分校，你知道，成绩还够得上。现在进加州大学洛杉矶分校更难了。是啊。是啊。而且我……那是真的吗？是啊。我在那儿表现得不好。我只是有点没法融入，我当时就想，好吧，我就是想做这一行。所以我退学回了纽约。那么，你当时有没有感到一种压力，就是为了
make ends meet? Knowing that, okay, now I'm all in. I'm not going to study any other career. I'm quitting college. I'm moving to New York. Did you have that sense of like, well, I'm going to have to make rent and provide... My parents were like, you could come home, stay home and figure it out. And, you know, they didn't kick me out. They didn't kick me out. But there was that feeling when I came back, when I finally quit school. And I remember just coming back to my parents' apartment and just like, and thinking, now what? Now what do I do? How do I go forward? And so, I started, you know, I worked as a busboy at a restaurant on Columbus Avenue. And then I started going to acting classes and started auditioning. But it took me about three years to actually
维持生计？知道自己已经破釜沉舟了。我不打算学习任何其他职业。我要退学。我要搬到纽约去。你有没有那种感觉，就是，好吧，我得付房租，得养活自己……我父母说，你可以回家，待在家里，慢慢想办法。而且，你知道，他们没有把我赶出去。他们没把我赶出去。但当我回来，当我最终退学时，确实有那种感觉。我记得回到父母的公寓时，我就在想，现在怎么办？我现在该做什么？我该怎么走下去？所以，我开始，你知道，我在哥伦布大道的一家餐馆当服务生。然后我开始上表演课，开始试镜。但我花了大约三年时间才真正
get any work. Did you worry that you were going to get out from under the immense shadow of your parents? I guess somewhere I did. But I think when you're that young and you just sort of have this idea of what you want to do, you don't think about it that way. Yeah. I don't know how you felt about it. I just never thought about it that way. I knew that I had to figure out how to do my thing. But, and it was a little bit sometimes daunting because I would go in and, you know, sometimes you're not, when you're not anonymous and you're not, and I wasn't very good too. I wasn't great at auditioning. I wasn't really that comfortable as an actor. And so, I would sort of fail a lot and not, not anonymously, you know, be like, Oh, Jerry Nanskid came in
得到工作。你是否担心自己会一直活在你父母巨大的阴影之下？我想在某种程度上是有的。但我认为当你那么年轻，只是对你想做的事情有个想法时，你不会那样去想。是啊。我不知道你是怎么想的。我只是从来没那样想过。我知道我必须想办法做我自己的事。但是，这有时确实有点令人望而生畏，因为我会去试镜，你知道，有时候你不是，当你不是默默无闻的时候，而且你不是，我当时演得也不太好。我不擅长试镜。作为演员，我真的不太自在。所以我经常失败，而且不是，不是默默无闻地失败，你知道，就像，哦，杰瑞·南斯基德来了
and it wasn't that great. Did you ever see, did you ever see though your mom or dad, like, with the ups and downs of getting parts, not getting jobs, struggling here and there, then maybe soaring and then maybe coming back down all the rollercoaster of doing the business that ever sway you from not wanting to do it? No, it didn't. I mean, I was, I don't, you know, at that time I was so thinking about my own thing and like, I wasn't even thinking about where my parents were because they were who they were. But when I look back at it now, and I've been working on a documentary about my parents. Oh, that's cool. That's really cool. Yeah. And it's been really interesting to kind of, you know, kind of look at their, you know,
演得不怎么样。你有没有见过你父母，经历过接戏的起起落落，没接到工作，这里挣扎一下，那里挣扎一下，然后可能又飞黄腾达，接着可能又跌落谷底，这种做这一行的过山车经历，有没有让你动摇过，不想做这一行？没有，并没有。我是说，我当时满脑子想的都是我自己的事，我甚至没去想我父母处在什么位置，因为他们就是他们。但现在回想起来，我一直在制作一部关于我父母的纪录片。哦，那很酷。真的很酷。是啊。而且能去，你知道，去审视他们的，你知道，
my dad saved everything. So there's so much footage and writing and all these great, you know, archives of stuff that they had, but they were going through kind of a tougher time when I quit school and came back and they were trying to figure out who they were at that point in their career. But I was so unaware of that because I was just thinking of my own thing. And now when I look back at it, you know, they were, they were having to figure out like, I was probably, I'm now my dad's age when I came home from school, you know, and I'm thinking about what he was doing then and trying to find, not till Seinfeld really, because he loved performing and he loved being, you know, he just loved doing it. And at that time I was pre-Seinfeld. He was sort of
我父亲保存了一切。所以有大量的影像资料、文字记录，还有所有那些他们留下的很棒的档案，但当我退学回来时，他们正经历一段比较艰难的时期，他们当时在职业生涯中也在努力寻找自己的定位。但我当时完全没意识到这一点，因为我只顾着想我自己的事。现在回想起来，你知道，他们当时不得不去弄清楚，我现在的年纪可能和我从学校回家时我父亲的年纪差不多，你知道，我在想他当时在做什么，在努力寻找，直到《宋飞正传》才真正找到，因为他热爱表演，他热爱成为，你知道，他就是热爱做这件事。而那时我还在《宋飞正传》之前。他当时有点
trying to figure out not being in the comedy act by mom anymore, you know, how to figure it out. Ben, do you ever wonder about just sort of in the context of your own relationships, your parents were performers, and then your kids and think about what their perspective is of of you guys? Or Jason, do you think about it? Because I've thought about it a few times now, recently, especially as the kids are getting older and becoming teenagers, about how, what a weird, I always make the joke when the kids come to, anytime they come to work with me, I'm like, Hey, is it fun watching dad get his makeup put on? You know, because how fucking weird is that? Or watching them, you know, 50 people dressed trying to make my hair look okay. And then like,
在努力弄清楚不再和我妈一起演喜剧之后，你知道，该怎么去应对。本，你有没有想过，在你自己的关系中，你的父母是表演者，然后是你的孩子们，你会想他们是怎么看待你们的吗？或者杰森，你有想过吗？因为我最近确实想过几次，尤其是孩子们长大成了青少年，关于那种，多么奇怪，我总是开玩笑说，当孩子们来，任何时候他们来我工作的地方，我就说，嘿，看爸爸化妆好玩吗？你知道，因为那有多他妈的奇怪啊？或者看着他们，你知道，50个人围着试图让我的头发看起来不错。然后就像，
we'll put that other shirt on. And like in front of my son, who's 13, he must be like, what is going on? Do you guys think about that? I don't. I don't. I don't. Just because you're used to it? Yeah. Well, I think they get it at this age now, I guess, but it's, it is odd for sure. Yeah, I mean, my kids are my daughter's 20, and my son's going to be 17. And they both have very, you know, clear points of view on show business and acting and, you know, their perception of my career and Christine's career, and, you know, they've grown up around it. So they have their own ideas about it, which is interesting to me. And they've, they've watched all of that stuff. And I think it is,
我们要换上那件衬衫。就像在我13岁的儿子面前，他肯定在想，这到底是怎么回事？你们有想过吗？我没有。我没有。我没有。只是因为你习惯了？是啊。嗯，我想他们现在这个年纪能理解了，我想，但这确实很奇怪。是啊，我是说，我的孩子们，我女儿20岁了，我儿子快17岁了。他们对演艺圈和表演都有非常，你知道，清晰的观点，而且，你知道，他们对我的职业生涯和克里斯汀的职业生涯的看法，而且，你知道，他们是在这种环境中长大的。所以他们有自己的想法，这对我来说很有趣。而且他们，他们看过所有那些东西。而且我认为这确实，
a lot of it is kind of weird, but it's also, they see the perspective on it too. And, you know, that I love doing it. And I think they get the positive part of it too. But it's something that I grew up with too. I was around my parents getting makeup on and all these visceral memories of that and loving it, you know, like loving being around the backstage of it and all that. Because it's different. They're not going to an office. Now you mentioned Christine, of course, Jason and I know Christine very well from Arrested Development days. And we got to spend a lot of time with her and amazing, just awesome. And every time I think about the other thing I think about when I think about you and Arrested Development, it reminds
很多时候确实有点奇怪，但同时，他们也能看到其中的视角。而且，你知道，我热爱做这件事。我想他们也能理解其中积极的一面。但这也是我从小就接触的东西。我身边就是我父母化妆，还有所有那些生动的记忆，而且热爱它，你知道，就像热爱待在后台，所有这些。因为这不一样。他们不是去办公室。现在你提到了克里斯汀，当然，杰森和我从《发展受阻》时期就非常了解克里斯汀。我们有很多时间和她在一起，太棒了，简直太棒了。而且每次我想到，当我想到你和《发展受阻》时，我还会想到另一件事，它让我想起
me of the Ben Stiller show because you guys were on the air for one year and you won the Emmy for Best Comedy. That's right. Which is very... It was crazy because we'd already been canceled too. We were already canceled. And so when we won, David Cross said to Jason and me, I don't know, Jason, you remember like, uh-oh, this doesn't look good. I've been down this path before. Right. Talk to me a little, talk to us a little bit about the Ben Stiller show, how it came to be and how it burns so bright and so quickly. No, was this, this was before or after SNL? Uh, this was after SNL. I was asked SNL for literally for six weeks, six weeks. And why did you jump? Go SNL first. I mean, it's...
《本·斯蒂勒秀》，因为你们播了一年就赢得了艾美奖最佳喜剧。没错。这非常……这太疯狂了，因为我们当时已经被取消了。我们已经被取消了。所以当我们获奖时，大卫·克罗斯对杰森和我，我不知道，杰森，你还记得吗，就像，哦，不，这看起来不太妙。我以前走过这条路。没错。跟我聊聊，跟我们聊聊《本·斯蒂勒秀》，它是怎么诞生的，又是怎么燃烧得如此灿烂又如此迅速。不，这是，这是在《周六夜现场》（SNL）之前还是之后？呃，这是在《周六夜现场》之后。我实际上在《周六夜现场》待了六周，六周。那你为什么要跳槽？先去《周六夜现场》。我是说，这……
You've probably told the story a million times. I'm so sorry. Well, you know, yeah, no, I basically got on SNL because I made a short film that was a takeoff on The Color of Money, which was called The Hustler of Money. This is the adult film. Yes. And I was doing an impression of Tom Cruise and Jim Downey, who was the head writer at the time. Sure. He, you know, he liked it and they, and Lorne put it on the air and then they said, you can come and audition and be an apprentice writer and a featured player. And I wanted to make short films. I wanted to do, I wanted to direct little films like Albert Brooks did and, you know, which I grew up watching
你可能已经讲过一百万次这个故事了。我很抱歉。嗯，你知道，是啊，不，我基本上是因为拍了一部短片才进了《周六夜现场》，那是对《金钱本色》的恶搞，叫《金钱骗子》。这是那部成人电影吗？是的。我在模仿汤姆·克鲁斯，而当时的总编剧吉姆·唐尼。当然。他，你知道，他很喜欢，然后他们，洛恩把它播出了，然后他们说，你可以来试镜，做一名实习编剧和特约演员。我想拍短片。我想做，我想导演像阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯那样的小电影，你知道，我从小看着他长大，
and thinking that's, you know, that's the funniest thing, like him doing, you know, the new fall season where he, you know, make fun of the show and the shows were coming out and things like that. And they weren't doing that at the time. It was pre all the Lonely Island guys and all that. So I was just there as like, as a featured player and I was not great at live performing. I did not like it. I would get nervous. I didn't feel like I could really do my thing. And it was, and it was hard to navigate. And I had a chance to do what I wanted to do on MTV, because MTV was doing these little, they, you know, sort of like half video show, like basically like they showed, if you showed videos, you could do comedy sketches, but it had to be like
觉得那是，你知道，最有趣的事情，就像他做的，你知道，新秋季档，他，你知道，拿节目开玩笑，节目刚出来的时候，诸如此类。他们当时没做那个。那是在所有“孤独岛”那帮人之前。所以我只是作为一个特约演员在那里，我不擅长现场表演。我不喜欢它。我会紧张。我觉得我没法真正做我自己的事。而且，而且很难驾驭。我有机会在MTV做我想做的事，因为MTV当时在做这些小节目，他们，你知道，有点像半视频节目，基本上就像他们播放视频，你可以做喜剧小品，但必须是，你知道，一半视频一半喜剧。所以他们基本上是在说，如果你想做那个，你可以在这里做。所以我决定去做了。谁在MTV支持你？你还记得吗？嗯，我是说，道格·赫尔佐格。是啊，他很棒。你知道，运营那个网络。是啊。还有弗雷斯顿。是啊，汤姆·弗雷斯顿。他给了我们机会。伟大的汤姆·弗雷斯顿。是啊。顺便说一句，世界上最有趣的男人，汤姆·弗雷斯顿。他启发了多塞克（Dos Equis）的整个广告活动。他确实是。没多少人知道这一点。是啊，他就是。他真的是。我从来没真正那么了解他，但他看起来总是非常引人入胜。他是最好的人。他是最有趣的。你可以，你可以走进一个房间
half and half videos and comedy. And so they were basically saying, if you want to do that, you can do that here. So I decided to go do that. Who championed you at MTV? Do you remember? Well, I mean, Doug Herzog. Yeah, he's great. You know, running the network. Yeah. And Freston too. Yeah, Tom Freston. He gave us a shot. Great Tom Freston. Yeah. And the most interesting man in the world, Tom Freston, by the way. He inspired that whole campaign for Dosec. He really is. Not a lot of people know that. Yeah, he is. He truly is. I've never really known him that well, but he always seems incredibly intriguing. He's the best guy. He's the most interesting. You can, you can walk into a room
和地球上最大的音乐明星在一起，每个人都只想和弗雷斯顿聊天。是啊。这是一个真实的故事。那是在MTV一段有趣的时期，因为他们刚开始做节目。所以他们让我们做我们自己的事。然后从那以后，福克斯的某个人，在福克斯刚起步的福克斯电视网看到了我们在做什么，说，嘿，来开发点什么吧。HBO在制作它，克里斯·阿尔布雷希特，他是HBO的一位高管。我们当时在为HBO和福克斯做，HBO独立制作。所以我们基本上花了大约两年时间开发这个小品秀。我们为它拍了大约三个试播集。每次我们都弄不清楚，他们弄不清楚构思这个节目的最好方式是什么。所以我们尝试了。
with the biggest music stars on the planet and everybody just wants to talk to Freston. Yeah. This is a true story. And that was an interesting time at MTV because they were just starting to do programming. So they let us do our thing. And then from that, someone Fox, at the Fox fledgling Fox network saw what we were doing and said, hey, come and develop something. HBO was producing it. Chris Albrecht, who was an executive at HBO. And we were doing it for HBO and Fox, HBO independent production. So we were basically for like two years developing this sketch show. And we did like three pilots for it. Every time we couldn't figure out, they couldn't figure out what was the best way to frame the show. So we tried.
谁在和你一起写那个？是你。你是掌舵人。卡皮奥和奥登科克。起初是我和杰夫·卡恩，他是我的，我的室友和写作搭档。我们当时在做一个表演，后来变成了那个MTV节目。然后我遇到了贾德，我和贾德一拍即合。他在做单口喜剧。我想他在做年轻喜剧演员特辑之类的。我们就开始一起混。我当时去即兴表演俱乐部，看珍妮·加罗法洛和鲍勃，我和鲍勃是在《周六夜现场》认识的，当时我在那儿。他当时在和柯南一起写剧本，还有安迪·迪克，做单口喜剧。安迪·迪克当时其实在芝加哥。我在芝加哥拍了一部电影叫《亲密关系》，
Who was writing that with you? It was you. You were at the helm. At Capitao and Odenkirk. And first it was me and Jeff Khan, who was my, my roommate and writing partner. And we were doing an act that we then turned into that MTV show. And then I met Judd and Judd and I clicked. He was doing stand up. And I think he was doing like the young comedian special or something. And we just started hanging out. And I was going and hanging out at the improv and watching Jeanine Garofalo and Bob and Bob and I had met at SNL when I was there. And he was writing at the time with Conan and so Andy Dick to and stand up. Andy Dick was actually in Chicago at the time. And I did a movie in Chicago called Next of Ken,
这部帕特里克·斯威兹的电影。我在那儿的时候拍了一部短片，我遇到了安迪·迪克。安迪·迪克来了。是啊。字面上说，我遇到安迪·迪克的方式是我在芝加哥的酒店里。他敲了门。我打开门，走廊的地板上躺着一个婴儿。他把他年幼的儿子留在了地板上。对于一个家伙来说。有这种方式，是啊，忘了。我后来收养了，不。所以，是啊。总之，这就是那个团队聚在一起的方式。是啊。那太疯狂了。好吧。所以然后你做，你做，我只是想弄清楚，你有了整个团队，因为我就是喜欢这一切的起源。所以你有像，你和鲍勃和贾德，你们在做《本·斯蒂勒秀》。你们被取消了。你们赢得了艾美奖最佳喜剧
this Patrick Swayze movie. And I made a short while I was there and I met Andy Dick. Andy Dick came. Yeah. And literally Andy Dick, the way I met Andy Dick was I was at my hotel in Chicago. And he knocked on the door. I opened the door and there was just an infant laying on the floor in the hallway. He left his infant son on the floor. For a guy. There's this way of, yeah, forget. I later adopted and no. So yeah. So anyway, that's how the group came together. Yeah. That's crazy. All right. So then you do, you do, I just want to get you've got this whole crew because I just love the genesis of all this. So you've got like, it's like you and Bob and Judd and you're doing the Ben Stiller show. You guys get canceled. You win the Emmy for best comedy
在节目被取消之后，这就像，你的获奖感言是什么？就像，嘿，去你的，福克斯，或者类似的话。表达得不是很清楚。我当时就像，我想是，嘿，福克斯，你们错过了一些东西，或者类似的话。是啊。所以然后你做了那个。那会给他们点颜色看看。你直接去拍了《现实咬人》。嗯，我正想说，所以几年之内，你拍了《现实咬人》，你参演，你导演。你导演的第一部电影是你写的吗，对吧？海伦·切尔德里斯写的。是的。这是我作为导演的第一部电影。我在我们制作《本·斯蒂勒秀》的时候就在开发它，和海伦一起，她写的是关于她自己的生活。然后节目被取消了。就在薇诺娜·瑞德说她想拍那部
after the show's canceled, which is like, what was your speech? Like, Hey, fuck you, Fox or something like that. It wasn't very articulate. I was like, I think it was like, Hey, Fox, you missed something here or something. Yeah. So then you do that. That'll show them. You go right onto reality bites. Well, I was going to say, so like within a couple of years, you go into reality bites, which you act in, which you direct. Did you write your first film as a director, right? Helen Childress wrote it. Yes. It's my first film as a director. I'd been developing it while we were working on the Ben Stiller show with Helen, who wrote it about her life. And then the show got canceled. And just about the time when Nona Ryder said she wanted to do the
电影的时候，这让它成为了现实。所以那是，那是原因。约翰·斯图尔特也在里面吗？约翰·斯图尔特？没有。他在吗？没有。谁在那部电影里？在《现实咬人》里？是啊，叫伊桑·霍克。没错。哦，是啊。我总是把那两个人搞混。这总是发生在我身上。我是伊桑·霍克的粉丝。我要记录在案，说我是伊桑·霍克的粉丝。伊桑太棒了。他太棒了。那你最近看他演《真实西部》了吗？没有，我想看。和保罗·达诺一起？天哪。我一直在观察一种叫大流行病的东西，本。继续。大流行病之前。天哪，我去看那个东西了吗？你在说什么？我们直接进入《我为玛丽狂》，在《现实咬人》之后？如果是的话，不。
movie, which made it happen. So that was, that was the reason. Wasn't John Stuart in that as well? John Stuart? No. Was he? No. Who was in that film? In reality bites? Yeah, named Ethan Hawke. Yep. Oh yeah. I always get those two confused. It always happens to me. I'm an Ethan Hawke fan. I'm going to go on the record and say I'm an Ethan Hawke fan. Ethan's amazing. He's amazing. So did you see him do True West recently? No, I wanted to. With Paul Dana? Oh my God. I've been observing a thing called the pandemic Ben. Go on. Pre-pandemic. Christ, did I go to the thing? What are you talking about? Do we go right into there's something about Mary after reality bites? And if so, no.
不，不，不。那里有大约五年的空档。去哪了，杰森？你的嘉宾？是啊。抱歉。嗯，那是维基百科。是他们的错。《王牌特派员》是在《我为玛丽狂》之前吗？是的。是的。好吧。所以那是你导演的第二部电影。是啊，《王牌特派员》。不可思议的电影。我也很喜欢那部电影。当时评价不太好。他们就是没看懂。他们当时没看懂。哦，我觉得它太棒了。就像，就像《本·斯蒂勒秀》一样。本，你有没有放，我们现在要连珠炮式地提问了。你有没有放《王牌特派员》，欧文·威尔逊在里面有个小角色？是这样吗？我就是那样认识欧文的。那是在《瓶装火箭》之后，因为那是95年左右出的。
No, no, no. There's a, there's like a five year gap there. Where'd it go, Jason? Your guest? Yeah. Sorry. Well, it's Wikipedia. It's their fault. Was Cable Guy before there's something about Mary? Yes. Yes. Okay. So that was a second, second film that you directed. Yeah, Cable Guy. Incredible film. I loved that film too. Not really well received at the time. They just didn't get it. They didn't get it at the time. Oh, I thought it was fantastic. Just like, just like the Ben Stiller show. Ben, did you put, we're going, we're firing away questions now. Did you put Cable Guy, Owen Wilson is in there in a small role? Is that right? That's how I met Owen. And it was right after Bottle Rocket because that came out about 95.
完全正确。我记日期很准。我看了《瓶装火箭》的短片。有一个黑白的《瓶装火箭》短片。我也看了那个。是啊。不可思议。不可思议。而且《瓶装火箭》这部电影是最好的电影之一。我记得有一次，这是我对欧文·威尔逊的回忆。我看了那部电影。我当时住在纽约。我就想，这太他妈酷了，这帮混蛋拍的电影。然后我去洛杉矶，碰巧在代客泊车那儿看到他。我就想，看那个。那是《瓶装火箭》里的那个家伙。然后他在《王牌特派员》里。然后我就想，是啊，我有点爱上欧文了。嗯，我就想，这家伙是我见过最有趣的人。我一个人去世纪城剧院看了《瓶装火箭》
That's exactly right. I'm so good with dates. I saw the Bottle Rocket short. There was a Black and White Bottle Rocket short. I saw that too. Yeah. Incredible. Incredible. And the film Bottle Rocket is one of the best films. And I remember one time, here's my recollections of Owen Wilson. I see that movie. I was living in New York at the time. I was like, this is fucking cool, this movie, these assholes made. And then I go to LA and I happen to see him like at valet. And I'm like, look at that. That's the guy from Bottle Rocket. And then he's in Cable Guy. And then I'm like, yeah, I sort of fell in love with Owen. Well, I was like, this guy is the funniest guy I've ever seen. I went, I went to see Bottle Rocket by myself at the Century City Theater or
或者类似的地方。我刚雇他拍《王牌特派员》。我看了那部电影。我一个人笑了五分钟，整部电影都在笑。我就想，这是最有趣的，天哪，这家伙太不可思议了。太有趣了。他的表达方式太独特了。哦，伙计。我知道。所以你和他拍了多少部电影？《王牌特派员》之后下一部是，是什么，你们在《警界双雄》之前又合作了吗？我现在很紧张，因为我不记得了。没错。《超级名模》。《超级名模》是2001年的。是啊，我们合作了。我是说，我们拍了一部叫《永恒午夜》的电影，那是一部小独立电影，我演杰瑞·斯塔尔，一个沉迷海洛因的喜剧编剧。他在里面演我最好的朋友。那是98年的。谁写了《精灵总动员》。
something. And I had just hired him for Cable Guy. And I watched that movie. I started laughing like five minutes in by myself for the whole movie. I was like, this is the funniest, like, oh my God, this guy is incredible. So funny. His delivery was so peculiar. Oh man. I know. So how many films have you done with him? And was the next one after Cable Guy, was it what, did you guys work together again before Starsky and Hutch? I'm stressing out now because I can't remember. Right. Zoolander. Zoolander was 2001. Yeah, we did. I mean, we did a movie called Permanent Midnight, where it was like this little indie where I played Jerry Stahl, who was a comedy writer, who was addicted to heroin. And he played my best friend in that. That was 98. Who wrote on Elf.
是啊，没错。我妈其实也在里面。然后我们做了什么？我们做了，然后我们一起拍了《超级名模》，那是2000年，2001年左右。然后我想《警界双雄》是在那之后，那是，当然，杰森。你可能和他拍了六部吧？七部？我想有人说我们拍了11部。不可能。没错。因为然后你们一起拍了所有的《博物馆奇妙夜》电影。没错。那里有三部。除了我们从来没真正一起工作，因为他在里面像个小人。哦，是的。没错。没错。就像个小雕像。所以我去。哦，对了。这就是他们工作的方式。就像我们在纽约自然历史博物馆开始拍了一天或两天
Yeah, exactly. And which my mom was on, actually. And then what did we do? We did, and then we did Zoolander together, which was like 2000, 2001. Then I think Starsky and Hutch was after that, which was, of course, Jason. You've probably done like what, six with him? Seven with him? I think somebody said we've done like 11. No way. Right. Because then you did all the night of the museum movies together. Exactly. That's three there. Except we never actually worked together because he was like a little person in it. Oh, yes. Right. Right. Right. Like a little figurine. So I would go. Oh, that's right. This is how they would work. It's like we would go to the Museum of Natural History in New York at the beginning for a day or maybe two days to shoot
外景。然后我们去温哥华待了五个月，在冬天的中间，在摄影棚里，那是，你知道，假的博物馆。然后欧文在最后三天进来，拍了他所有的戏份，你知道，在绿幕前抢了整部电影。是啊。没错。和不可思议的加拿大火箭船，肖恩·利维。天哪。是啊。我爱他。那个火球。我为续集《博物馆奇妙夜2》试镜过。真的吗？我去读给肖恩·利维听，我说，你知道，也许我演了那个场景，我说，你知道，如果这个东西和这个东西很有趣，我把这个东西拿出来，我做了这个，他说，是啊，你想导演它吗？谢谢你的到来。不，说真的？是啊。我带着
the exteriors. Then we would go to Vancouver for five months in the middle of winter and be in the studio where it was the, you know, the fake museum. And then Owen would come in the last three days and shoot all of his stuff and, you know, steal the movie against a green screen. Yeah. Exactly. With the incredible Canadian rocket ship, Sean Levy. Oh my God. Yeah. I love him. The ball of fire. I auditioned for the sequel, the night, night at the museum too. Really? And I went and then ran, read for Sean Levy and I go, you know, maybe I did the scene and I go, you know, maybe funny if this thing and this and I took out the thing here and I did this and he goes, yeah, you want to direct it? Thanks for coming. No, seriously? Yeah. I came in
太多的想法进去了。他那儿有一把偷偷摸摸的刀，穿着他那套加拿大西装。他确实有。他时不时会掏出来。他是节目的朋友。他是节目的朋友。肖恩是节目的朋友。他很棒。他很棒。所以你，安德鲁，你说是的，你想导演它吗？因为那是什么样的机会。顺便说一句，她是那个机会。我们在那部电影里建立了联系。所以本，有多难？你希望，从职业遗憾的角度，你希望把贝特曼从《警界双雄》里剪掉吗？那会排在前面吗？简单。这是一个非常容易的剪辑。不需要太多修剪。但你们也拍了，我是在开玩笑，因为你们拍了几部电影。你们还拍了《躲避球》。没错。那是一个下午。
with too many ideas. He's got a sneaky, he's got a sneaky knife there and that Canadian kind suit of his. He sure does. He'll whip it out every once in a while. He's a friend of the program. He's a friend of the program. Sean's a friend of the program. He's great. He's great. So what do you, Andrew, do you say yes, you want to direct it? Because what an opportunity. By the way, she's the opportunity. We bonded. We bonded on that movie. So Ben, how hard was it? Do you wish, regret wise career, do you wish cut Bateman out of Starsky? Would that would be up there? Simple. It's a real easy cut. Not a lot of trimming. But then you guys also do, I was joking because you guys did a few movies. You also did dodgeball. That's right. That was an afternoon.
是啊。但我感觉那个下午真的留下了印记。我是说，我看到了那些梗图。它帮了我。杰森，你在里面太搞笑了。谢谢。那是《发展受阻》午休时间拍的。哦，真的吗？你是认真的吗？我记得那个。我开车去，我们在哪拍的？像玫瑰碗，我想。是，哦，你们在玫瑰碗拍的吗？因为我们也去长滩拍了。是啊。两个地方之一。我是说，真的，那真的很有趣。那是一次非常有趣的经历。我记得走出那个放映厅，我坐在托德·菲利普斯旁边，在韦斯特伍德的首映式上。我记得看着它，我根本不知道那部电影是什么。我是说，同样，我只在那儿待了半小时，你知道，做，
Yeah. But I feel like that afternoon really made a mark. I mean, I see the memes. It helped me. Jason, you were hilarious in that. Thank you. That was during a lunch hour from Arrested Development. Oh, really? Are you serious? I remember that. I drove down to the, where did we shoot it? Like the Rose Bowl, I think. It was, well, the, oh, did you do that at the Rose Bowl? Because we also shot down in Long Beach too. Yeah. One of the two. I mean, really, that was really fun. It was a really fun experience. And I remember walking out of that screening, I was sitting next to Todd Phillips at the screening, the premier of that in Westwood. I remember watching it and I had no idea what the movie was. I mean, again, it was only there for a half an hour, you know, doing,
做这个，你知道，基本上是一个对着麦克风的固定镜头，演某个白痴色彩解说员。我根本不知道那种色彩，那种基调，那种喜剧基调。所以我直到在放映厅看到它才知道电影是关于什么的。我们放映结束了，显然《躲避球》，非常，非常有趣，极其通俗。但我猜我只是没准备好那种风格，那种幽默的味道。然后和托德·菲利普斯走出来，做那种禁忌的事情，当你走在过道上，谈论这部电影时，你知道，我说，不，我说，天哪，我不知道。我是说，你怎么看？他说，那真是太棒了。我说，真的吗？他说，是啊，我说，我告诉你，托德，我和你打赌一百美元，
doing this, you know, basically a lock off me behind a microphone playing some idiot color announcer. And I didn't have no idea of the color of the tone, the comedic tone of that. And so I didn't really know what the film was about till I saw it at the screening. And we finished the screening and, and obviously dodgeball, very, very funny, incredibly broad. But I guess I just wasn't prepared for the style, the flavor of humor. And then walking out with Todd Phillips and doing the taboo thing when you're going up the aisle way, talking about the film, you know, and I said, no, I said, boy, I don't know. I mean, what do you think? He's like, that was pretty damn good. I go, really? He said, yeah, I said, I'll tell you what, Todd, I'll make you a hundred dollar
这东西票房不会超过5000万美元。他说，我跟你赌一千。我说，一言为定。我想它做到了。它票房多少？我想它第一个周末就做到了那个数字或者类似的东西。它表现很好。它确实开画第一名。我知道那是我的天哪。多么令人惊讶。你付给他了吗？杰森，你付给他一千美元了吗？我不这么认为。没有。托德现在过得不错。这就是为什么他是托德·菲利普斯。拜托。是啊，你欠他一千美元，他可以来拿。但你，但这很有趣，杰森，因为我觉得你完全抓住了电影的基调，虽然你不知道。嗯，更老，因为我记得。事实上，
bet. This thing doesn't do a dollar over 50 million dollars. He goes, I'll bet you a thousand. I said, you're on. I think it does. What does it do? Like, I think it did that in the first weekend or something. It did well. It actually had open number one. I know that it was my God. What a surprising. Did you pay him? Jason, did you pay him a thousand dollars? I don't think so. No. Todd's doing okay. That's why he's Todd Phillips. Come on. Yeah, you owe him a thousand dollars and he can come at it. But you, but that's, that's funny though, Jason, because I feel like you totally hit the tone of the movie without knowing it. Well, older because I remember. In fact,
杰森，你在你自己的电影里，你有你自己的小电影，这太棒了。我记得我第一次到片场时，我记得走下去，我找到了，我找到了你和罗斯在视频村。你们在拍不同的场景，我早到了点去化妆，因为，或者因为我，我的头发必须全部竖起来之类的。所以我当时就想，所以伙计们，所以竖起来的头发，就像那是基调。那是笑点。你们俩都说，是啊，是啊。我说，哈。然后我不知道是我的主意还是罗斯的还是你的。也许本，我说，嗯，就像，这个家伙会不会有一个像火焰般的躲避球颈部纹身？他们就像，是的。是的。
Jason, you were in your own movie, you had your own little movie going, which is amazing. I remember when I first got to the set, I remember going down, I found, I found you and Ross in Video Village. You guys were shooting a different scene and I got there a little early to get into makeup cause, or cause I, my hair had to get all spiked up and stuff. And so I was like, so guys, so the spiky hair, like that's the tone. That's the funny. And you guys were both like, yeah, yeah. I go, huh. And then I don't know whether it was my idea or Ross's or yours. Maybe Ben, I said, well, like, is it like, would this guy have like a flaming net neck tattoo of like a dodgeball on it? And there were like, yes. Yes.
就像一个火焰般的躲避球颈部纹身，我想我现在明白基调了。我想我明白了。是啊。你知道谁从来没真正理解吗？雷普·托恩，他在电影里太搞笑了。他从来没明白，而且我的，我的姐夫负责，布莱恩·泰勒负责照顾他。就像他是他的经纪人，得到了，是啊。他从来没真正，你知道，加入进来，但他太搞笑了，因为他只是表现得非常有趣。我最喜欢的，我最喜欢的雷普·托恩的故事是，我记得杰弗里和拉斯告诉我们，当他们在拍《拉里·桑德斯秀》时，他们在最后一季，他们说，他们决定要给加里·山德林。每个人都要凑钱
Like a flaming dodgeball neck tattoo is like, I think I got the tone now. I think I get it. Yeah. You know who never really understood was Rip Torn, who was so funny in the movie. He never got, and my, my brother-in-law was in charge, Brian Taylor was in charge of taking care of him for the movie. Like he was sort of like his hand line and got some, yeah. And he never really, you know, jumped on board, but he was so funny because he was just being really funny. My favorite, my favorite Rip Torn story was, I remember Jeffrey and Russ telling us when they were doing Larry Sanders and they were in their last season and they go, they decided that they're going to get Gary Shanling. Everybody's going to chip it
给他买辆车。他们拍了五、六季节目，每个人都要凑钱，这是一个大的杀青礼物，作为对加里的感谢。他们要给他买辆车。所以杰弗里负责去买，他走到雷普的更衣室，他敲了敲，敲了敲更衣室的门，雷普打开门说，是啊，什么？他说，哦，嘿，雷普，我们要，我们都在，我们都在凑钱。我们要给加里买个礼物，作为整个系列的杀青礼物。他说，是啊，我们要给他买什么？他说，嗯，我们决定我们都要凑钱。我们要给他买辆车。雷普看着他说，去你妈的。他砰地关上了门。他的回答是去你妈的。我想有一天在片场他决定他
and buy him a car. They've done the show for five, six seasons and everybody's going to chip in is this big wrap then is a thank you to Gary. They're going to get him a car. So Jeffrey's tasked with going to get it and he goes up to Rip's dressing room and he knocks on the, knocks up the dressing door and he goes, Rip opens it and goes, yeah, what? And he goes, oh, hey, Rip, we're going to, we're all, we're all pitching in. We're going to get Gary a gift for a wrap for the whole series. And he goes, yeah, what are we going to get him? And he goes, well, we've decided we're all going to chip in. We're going to get him in a car. Rip looks at him and goes, go fuck yourself. He slammed the door shut. His answer was go fuck yourself. I think one day on set he decided he
只是要去钓鱼。他就像离开去钓鱼了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。当你读《我为玛丽狂》的剧本时，你对那些导演、编剧有难以置信的信心，觉得那会是一个击中目标的靶子，还是看起来像是一次巨大的尝试？是啊，我记得非常清楚地读了剧本，而且，大声笑出来，读着剧本，想着这要么会非常，非常，非常有趣，要么就会很糟糕。它会像是有史以来最烂的电影。就像它不会成功。但就像那是你带给某样东西的价值的完美例子，那些像那样巨大的尝试，你需要一个本·斯蒂勒在中间。
was just going to go fishing. He like left to go fishing. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. When you read the script for There's Something About Mary, did you have like incredible faith in those directors, writers that it was all going to be a, a target that has hit or that seemed like a big swing? It was, yeah, I remember reading the script very clearly and, and laughing out loud reading the script and thinking that this will either be really, really, really funny or it'll just be awful. It'll be like just like the worst movie ever. Like it will not work. But like that's a perfect example of like the value you bring to something that's taking swings as big as that you need a Ben Stiller in the middle of it.
是啊，但他们，他们不是为了那部电影来找我的。我，我想参演那部电影。我在努力，你知道，进入那部电影。你在追逐它。是啊。因为我真的觉得它会非常有趣，但我不知道。然后就像和他们一起工作，和法雷利兄弟在片场工作，我实际上，那是我当时想，等一下，这真的会成功吗？因为那是一个如此奇怪的环境。因为那不是，那根本不像我待过的任何电影片场。就像，他们只是玩得很开心，互相开恶作剧，你知道，非常政治不正确的，恶作剧。把他们所有的朋友都放进场景里之类的。是啊，把朋友放进场景里，而不是
Yeah, but they weren't, they weren't coming after me for that movie. I was, I wanted to be in that movie. I was trying to, you know, get in that movie. You were chasing it. Yeah. And because I really did think it could be really funny, but I didn't know. And then like working with them, working with the Ferreles on the set, I was actually, that was where I was like, wait a minute, is this actually going to work? Because it was such a weird environment. Because it wasn't, it was just not like any movie set I'd ever been on. There was like, they were just having so much fun and playing practical jokes on each other, you know, very politically incorrect, practical jokes. Putting all their friends in scenes and stuff. Yeah, putting friends in scenes and not
真正谈论像动机之类的事情。而且，你知道，就像我会和他们争论像场景的逻辑，或者，你知道，哦，我在浴室里，我的，你知道，我的鸡鸡在拉链里。但就像，为什么所有这些人都在窗边走过？就像，我觉得我是在一部马克思兄弟的电影里或者类似的地方，你知道，或者就像，有，你知道，那个滴在我，我耳朵上的场景，你知道，我当时就想，为什么我耳朵感觉不到那个？为什么我感觉不到它？我们是不是应该设定我，就像，我小时候失去了耳朵的敏感度之类的？我的耳垂什么都感觉不到。他们就像，不，那会很有趣。很多那样的对话。本，别
really talking about like motivation or things like that. And, you know, like I would get into like arguments with them about like the logic of a scene or, you know, like, oh, I'm in the bathroom and my, you know, my dick's in the zipper. But like, why are all these people walking by the window? It's like, I felt like I was in a Mark's Brothers movie or something, you know, or like, there was like, you know, the scene where it's like dripping on my, my ear, you know, and I was like, why don't I feel that on my ear? Why wouldn't I feel it? Should we set up that I had, like, that I lost sensitivity in my ear when I was a child or something? My ear lobe doesn't feel anything. And they were like, no, it's gonna be funny. A lot of those conversations. Ben, don't
担心它。别他妈的本。所以我当时是个讨人厌的演员，杰森。没错。你是那个片场的贝特曼。是啊，完全是。嗯，我一直觉得如果我们再多工作两分钟，我们就能确定他失去了耳朵的敏感度。然后对于观众中任何愤世嫉俗的人，我们都照顾到了。那是我进行过的一次真实对话。一次严肃的对话。我会回应那个对话。哦，杰森会把它变成一个侧边栏。我会说，是的，在第20页，我们可以放下那个小面包屑。是啊，没错。我们过去总是，我总是，顺便说一句，他们的回答，我敢肯定总是像，你知道吗，本，别担心它。卡姆·尼利觉得它很有趣。但还有，还有那个，就像，
worry about it. Don't fucking Ben. So I was in the pain in the ass actor, Jason. Right. You were the Jason. You were the Bateman on that set. Yeah, totally. Well, I've always felt like if we just worked just two minutes longer, we can establish that he's lost sensitivity in the ear. And then for anyone who's a cynic in the audience, we got him covered. That's a real conversation I had. A serious conversation. And I would respond to that conversation. Oh, Jason would have turned that into a sidebar. I'd be like, yes, on page 20, we can drop that little bread crumb. Yeah, exactly. We used to always, I always, by the way, their answer, I'm sure was always like, you know what, Ben, don't worry about it. Cam Neely thinks it's funny. But also, and also that like,
我过去常对杰森说，有时候问问题。而且我不知道，顺便说一句，卡姆，怎么了？史上最伟大的冰球运动员之一。杰森，我们有时会说，嘿，你知道，为什么你不把它带到工作坊舞台或者七号舞台上？好吧，我们在那儿谈谈那个。今天先把场景拍完。嘿，本。所以当你，现在你正在做更大的事情，比如导演像《人生切割术》这样伟大的节目，以及你剩下的任何东西。更少精液的项目。是啊。你是吗？他完成了《金钱骗子》和《我为玛丽狂》。你在未来的项目中寻找更少精液的东西吗？去吧，肖恩。你是什么吸引你到某些项目？你是，例如，像《人生切割术》
I used to say to Jason, sometimes asking questions. And I don't know, by the way, what's up, Cam? One of the great all time hockey players. Jason, we sometimes go, hey, you know, why don't you take that over to workshop on the workshop stage or on stage seven? Okay, we'll talk about that over there. Let's just get the scene today. Hey, Ben. So when you, now that you are onto bigger things like directing great shows like Severance and whatever else you have left. Less cum laden projects. Yeah. Are you? He's finished with the hustler of money and there's something about Mary. Are you looking for less common in your future projects? Go, Sean. Are you what attracts you to certain projects? Are you like, for example, like Severance
有点科幻？你是科幻迷吗？你是因为它的挑战而接受它吗？他讨厌《星际迷航》。或者你知道那个吗？或者你只选择像，像，什么你不会选择的东西？在这一点上，我基本上就是凭直觉，老实说。就像，如果我读到什么东西或者我开始开发什么东西，那是因为它是我真的，我只是真的感到被它吸引，而且我真的很喜欢。就像，你会拍恐怖片吗？也许，但我不想为了拍而拍。或者你在说恐怖。或者你在说恐怖。好吧，抱歉。恐怖。好吧，很好。你知道，但就像《人生切割术》，我觉得它很有趣，
is a little sci-fi-y? Are you a sci-fi fan? Did you accept that because of the challenge of it? He hates Star Trek. Or do you know that? Or do you only choose things that are like, like, what wouldn't you choose? At this point, I kind of just go with a gut feeling, honestly. Like, if I read something or I start to develop something, it's because it's something that I'm really, I just really feel turned on by and I really like. Like, would you ever do a horror film? Maybe, but I wouldn't want to do it just to do it. Or you're saying horror. Or you're saying horror. Okay, sorry. Horror. Okay, good. You know, but like with Severance, it was, I thought it was funny,
实际上，当我读它的时候。是啊，它是。因为它让我想起了《办公室》和《办公空间》以及那种幽默，你知道，那种已经发展起来的东西。那种忧郁的凄凉幽默。是啊。不，它变得没那么有趣了。但就像，亚当在那方面很棒，你也很棒。是啊，我只是觉得从概念上讲，做那种幽默真的很有趣，但人们却不知道他们是谁，或者他们在做什么，或者为什么他们在那里。但他们却处于这种节奏中，你知道。我喜欢认识你们俩，亚当。我喜欢，并且在各方面都是你们俩的粉丝，看着这些场景，想着你们合作，对我来说看的时候非常令人兴奋，因为我看到了你们俩，他在以
actually, when I read it. Yeah, it is. Because it reminded me of the office and office space and that kind of humor, you know, that thing that's developed. That melancholy bleak humor. Yeah. No, it became much less funny. But like, that Adam's awesome at, you're awesome at. Yeah, I just thought conceptually, it was really interesting to do that kind of humor, but yet the people had no idea who they were or what they were doing or why they were there. But yet they're in this sort of rhythm, you know. I love knowing both you and Adam. I love and being such a fan of both of yours in every respect and watching the scenes and thinking about you guys collaborating to me is very exciting to watch because I see both of you guys, he's operating at
如此高的水平运作。我能感觉到你的手在里面，但不是那种强加于人的，但我能感觉到你们俩都在工作。因为你们是在《白日梦想家》认识的，对吧？是啊。太好了。本，这太好了，伙计。谢谢，伙计。我是说，你真的。嗯，谢谢。但我认为亚当很棒。我是说，我们在《白日梦想家》认识的。我在《非亲兄弟》里看到他，那真的让我大吃一惊，他在那部电影里有多有趣。就像，我无法停止看他演那些场景，你知道，餐桌场景，你知道，而且那不仅仅是像个混蛋之类的。就像他有这种精确度，这对我来说简直不可思议。我爱他。我想谈谈你导演、编剧和参演那些像
such a high level. And I can feel your hand in it as well, but not heavy-handed, but I can feel both of you guys working. Because you met on Walter Mitty, right? Yeah. It's so good. Ben, it's so good, man. Thanks, man. I mean, you're really. Well, thank you. But I think Adam is amazing. I mean, we met on Walter Mitty. I saw him in Step Brothers, which really just blew my mind how funny he was in that movie. It was just like, I couldn't stop watching him do those scenes where, you know, the dinner table scenes were, you know, and it was more than just being like a dick or whatever. Like he had just this level of specificity that just was incredible to me. I love him. I want to talk about like your ability to direct and write and act in stuff that's like
史诗般的东西的能力，但也像《白日梦想家》和《热带惊雷》，我觉得那些电影的范围和规模简直巨大，但你仍然能够用一些角色喜剧变得非常小和具体，那不是，那不是开玩笑。那不是这个。我是说，我想《热带惊雷》里有不可思议的笑话，但它仍然，我不知道，你能够管理，看起来像是在一个项目里有多种类型。这里没有真正的问题。这只是，只是钦佩。哦，谢谢。我是说，我，我觉得这就像不是，你知道，远离类型。你看过那部电影《世界上最糟糕的人》吗？还没，但保罗·托马斯·安德森在，在播客上，他在谈论。他在谈论它。嗯，它是，而且他也做到了。它是，你知道，我钦佩电影制作人，我还没
epic, but also like Walter Mitty and Tropic Thunder, I think the scope and scale of those movies are just enormous, but you're still able to get real small and specific with some character comedy that's not, it's not jokey. It's not this. I mean, I guess there's incredible jokes in Tropic Thunder, but it's still, I don't know, you're able to manage, it seems like multiple genres in one project. There's no real question here. It's just, just admiration. Oh, thanks. I mean, I, I think it's like not, you know, getting away from genres. Did you see that movie, The Worst Person in the World? Not yet, but Paul Thomas Anderson was on the, was on the podcast and he was talking. He was talking about it. Well, it's, and he does it too. It's, you know, I admire filmmakers and I haven't
做过这个，但那些只是说，去他的类型。我不关心类型，那些能够只是说，我要拍它们的电影制作人。也许在他们脑子里，他们认为这是这种类型，那种类型与那个有关，但他们只是要拍一些对他们来说是一部电影的东西，你知道，他们与之相关，而且他们觉得，让他们感觉到什么的电影。对我来说，就像我，我尽量不去想类型，你知道，那么多，只是试着去想，好吧，什么会让这个有趣？什么会让这个在这一刻真实？而这就是基调，你知道？什么会让它强大？就像《白日梦想家》，它只是，它只是在某些时候如此强大和沉重。当它，当它想要变成某种史诗寓言时，它做到了，当它
done this, but filmmakers who just say, screw it with genre. I don't care about the genre, who are able to just say, I'm going to make them. And maybe in their head, they're thinking it's this genre, that genre relates to that, but they're just going to make something that to them is a movie that, you know, that they relate to and that they feel, makes them feel something. And that's, for me, like I, I try not to think about the genre, you know, at that much and just try to go, okay, what's going to make this funny? What's going to make this real in this moment? And that's what tone is, you know? What's going to make it powerful? Like with MIDI, it was just, it was just so powerful and heavy at times. And when it, when it wanted to become sort of this epic fable it did, when it
做到这一点，但那些根本不在乎类型的电影制作人，他们不在乎什么类型，他们只是说，我要把电影拍出来。也许在他们脑海里，他们会想这是这种类型，那种类型与此相关，但他们只是想拍出一部对他们来说有共鸣、能让他们有所感触的电影。对我来说，我尽量不去想类型，只是试着去想，好吧，什么能让它变得有趣？什么能让这一刻变得真实？这就是基调，你知道吗？什么能让它变得有力量？就像《MIDI》一样，它有时就是那么有力量，那么沉重。当它想要变成那种史诗般的寓言时，它就做到了，当它
wanted to get really small and intimate, it did. And that was a passion project for you, Ben. It took you a long time to get that up there. And Steve Conrad did such an incredible job writing that. It's all Steve Conrad. He wrote the script and it came to me. And then that was one I also wanted to be a part of. And then Steve and I were able to connect on it. And I really loved working with him on it. He's doing incredible work on television too. Oh my God, Patriot. That show, like talk about defying genres, you know? Ben, you've always had a really great eye for, and we mentioned Owen, but you've had a really great eye for emerging talent. And you, you've always stayed really close to what's going on, especially in comedy, not in film in general, I think as well,
想要变得非常小众和亲密，它确实做到了。那对你来说是一个充满激情的项目，本。你花了很长时间才把它做出来。史蒂夫·康拉德在剧本创作上做得非常出色。这完全是史蒂夫·康拉德的功劳。他写了剧本，然后交给了我。那也是我想参与其中的一个项目。后来史蒂夫和我在这方面达成了共识。我真的很喜欢和他一起工作。他在电视领域也做着令人难以置信的工作。天哪，《爱国者》。那部剧，谈论打破类型限制，你知道吗？本，你一直有很好的眼光，我们提到了欧文，但你对新兴人才一直有很好的眼光。而且你，你一直非常关注正在发生的事情，特别是在喜剧方面，我认为在电影方面也是如此，
but, but, but especially comedy. Who are the people these days who are making you laugh? You're going, fuck, this is new. This is somebody doing something in a different, and you've always respected people who do it in a way like you said about Owen again, people who do it differently. Yeah. I mean, I feel like I'm, you know, I feel sometimes that I'm not as connected as I should be. I'm not seeing everything and out there because I kind of get wrapped up in working on the project I'm working on. And so I'll see people who come in and audition or read or, I don't watch as much television as I feel that I should. Are you good about watching films? I am not as good at, lately I'm not. I'm not as good at watching a lot of, I get in and I feel like it's,
但是，但是，尤其是喜剧。如今有哪些人让你发笑？你会说，该死，这是新的。这是某人在做一些不同的事情，而且你一直尊重那些以你所说的方式做事的人，就像你再次提到欧文一样，那些以不同方式做事的人。是的。我的意思是，我觉得我，你知道，我有时觉得我没有像我应该的那样与外界保持联系。我没有看到外面的一切，因为我有点沉浸在正在进行的项目中。所以我看到那些进来试镜或阅读的人，我没有看那么多我应该看的电视节目。你擅长看电影吗？我不擅长，最近我不擅长。我不擅长看很多电影，我进入状态，我觉得它是，
it's like there's so much to watch. Right. Yeah. You know, I did get recommended to watch this show Dave and, God, I really think it's good. So funny. There are some moments in that that are so funny. He's really specific. He's really honest. You know, he's the rapper Lil Dicky. It's, I thought it really developed over the two seasons. There's an episode with Cream Abdul-Jabbar that is so funny. Really? Where, yeah. And Cream Abdul-Jabbar is so good. I mean, he was good in airplane, but like he's really good. And, but Dave, to me, it's like this guy is do it. He's just being really, really honest and creating his own tone, but it's really funny. And, you know, it's, it's just, it's self-effacing, but it's honest. And I think that's, you know, to me, when you see
就像有太多东西可以看了。对。是的。你知道，有人推荐我看《戴夫》这部剧，天哪，我真的觉得它很好。太搞笑了。里面有一些时刻非常搞笑。他真的很具体。他真的很诚实。你知道，他是说唱歌手Lil Dicky。我觉得它在两季中真的发展得很好。有一集有卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔，非常搞笑。真的吗？是的。而且卡里姆·阿卜杜勒-贾巴尔演得太好了。我的意思是，他在《空前绝后满天飞》里演得很好，但他真的演得很好。而且，但对我来说，《戴夫》就像这个家伙在做这件事。他只是非常、非常诚实，创造了他自己的基调，但它真的很有趣。而且，你知道，它只是，它很自嘲，但很诚实。我认为这就是，你知道，对我来说，当你看到
somebody doing that, it's really exciting. Having done so much at such a high level for so long, you know, this qualifies as a completely fully realized career, yet you're still a young man. So the stuff that I'm assuming you want to still get done since you've kind of checked all boxes is just what, just a, a, a continue sort of an escalation in your taste, your talent, in the same genres and the same, you know, television, film, comedy, drama, whatever it is. It's just your taste is going to continue to evolve. And that's what you want to continue doing is just, he wants to know, he's trying to ask Ben, sorry, it's a long way to go. He's trying to ask if you're, if you're Oscar hunting. That's what he wants to know. Who isn't Jason? Right.
有人这样做时，这真的很令人兴奋。在这么高的水平上做了这么久，你知道，这算是一个完全实现的职业生涯，但你仍然是一个年轻人。所以我假设你仍然想完成的事情，既然你已经完成了所有的事情，只是什么，只是一个，一个，一个在你品味、才华上的持续提升，在相同的类型和相同的，你知道，电视、电影、喜剧、戏剧，无论它是什么。只是你的品味会继续进化。这就是你想继续做的事情，他想知道，他试图问本，抱歉，这还有很长的路要走。他试图问你是否在追求奥斯卡。这就是他想知道的。谁不是呢，杰森？对。
You know, or do you want to, or do you want to do something about a guy who is like in his early fifties, who started working out and he went to fight camp and he only plays 38. You know what I mean? Is that, is that a story that interests you? Like a guy, like he's unassuming, he's kind of dry. Shut it, Sean. I'm telling a story about a guy who nobody's ever seen before. Who's very well lit. Yeah. He's very well lit. I, um, no, I, you know, it's a good question, Jason. It's a really good question. And I am sort of constantly asking myself that, I guess, as I go through life these days, because I'm trying to find the balance and, you know, that's really important to me is the balance of being able to have my personal life that I feel good in. And I found over the years,
你知道，或者你想，或者你想做一个关于一个五十出头的人的故事，他开始锻炼，他去了训练营，他只演38岁。你知道我的意思吗？那是，那是一个让你感兴趣的故事吗？就像一个家伙，他谦逊，他有点冷幽默。闭嘴，肖恩。我正在讲一个没人见过的人的故事。他光线很好。是的，他光线很好。我，嗯，不，你知道，这是一个好问题，杰森。这是一个非常好的问题。我猜我最近在生活中经常问自己这个问题，因为我试图找到平衡，你知道，这对我来说真的很重要，那就是能够拥有让我感觉良好的个人生活。我多年来发现，
and I'm sure you've experienced, you've all experienced this, that it's challenging to do that. And I think I'm more self aware of these days about that. But I love, I love directing. I'm trying to reconnect with my acting self, you know, like I'm really trying to figure it out. I know I love acting, but I don't want to also do it. There's something, you know, just to be honest, there's something very, uh, the enticing about being an actor and being a star of things and having, you know, all that attention. Well, and also it's, it's, it's of all the jobs, producer, writer, director, actor, whatever. It's kind of like you have your shit and that's, you don't have to worry about all the big picture stuff. You know, you have to worry about your scene work. It's,
我相信你们都经历过，你们都经历过这一点，要做到这一点很有挑战性。我想我最近对此更有自我意识了。但我喜欢，我喜欢导演。我正在尝试与我的演员身份重新连接，你知道，就像我真的在试图弄清楚它。我知道我喜欢表演，但我也不想只做那个。你知道，老实说，作为一名演员，成为明星，拥有，你知道，所有的关注，是非常诱人的。嗯，而且，它是，它是，在所有工作中，制片人、编剧、导演、演员，无论什么。这有点像你有你的事，你不必担心所有的大局。你知道，你只需要担心你的场景工作。它是，
I think. Right. But that, that, I'm trying not to go, I don't want to go back to it just because I've kind of enjoy that part of it, you know, or the mula. The mula is really good too. But you enjoy working as an actor in, in what are like director vehicles, like working with some of your heroes. I would love to do that. Yes. I'd love to keep acting in other people's movies or even television shows too. Figuring out a comedy to do. I would, I would love to jump back in. I've been talking to Mike judge about something. And I think I love Mike judge. And so what a, what a, Jason, you worked with him. What a great, what an incredible comedic voice. What, what about doing something like Sean does though? Like, would you be able to go,
我想。对。但那，那，我尽量不去想，我不想回到它身边，只是因为我有点享受那部分，你知道，或者钱。钱也很好。但你喜欢在导演的作品中担任演员，比如与你的一些英雄合作。我很乐意那样做。是的。我很乐意继续在别人的电影甚至电视节目中表演。弄清楚一部喜剧来做。我，我很乐意跳回去。我一直在和迈克·贾奇谈论某件事。我想我喜欢迈克·贾奇。所以什么，什么，杰森，你和他合作过。多么伟大的，多么令人难以置信的喜剧声音。那做一些像肖恩做的事情呢？就像，你能够去，
Sean's in Chicago talking about sacrificing. He goes there and he's rehearsing and doing this play nonstop every day too. Ben, I don't know if you know this, Sean's had incredible reviews for his film. I want to see this play and I had a personal interest in the Oscar LeVance story because Stuart Kornfeld had, had championed it for a long time. And I've got, I've got up in my living room, a Richard Avedon portrait of LeVance from late in his life. Incredible shot when he, you know, very near the end, which just really kind of a striking photo. Yes, I know the one. To Sean, it totally makes sense for you to give it to Sean. Yeah, just give it to him. Or come over to my house and look at it. Yeah. Just commit to giving it to him now.
肖恩在芝加哥谈论牺牲。他去那里，他每天都在排练和表演这部戏。本，我不知道你是否知道这一点，肖恩的电影评论非常好。我想看这部戏，我对奥斯卡·勒凡的故事有个人兴趣，因为斯图尔特·科恩菲尔德长期以来一直支持它。我的客厅里有一张理查德·阿维顿拍摄的勒凡晚年的肖像。当他，你知道，非常接近生命尽头时拍摄的令人难以置信的照片，这真是一张引人注目的照片。是的，我知道那张。对肖恩来说，把它给肖恩完全有意义。是的，就给他吧。或者来我家看看它。是的。现在就承诺把它给他。
You're on the show. But we, could you ever see yourself been doing that, doing eight shows a week on Broadway? You've done that. Yes, I could. I have done it not for a long time. Yeah. And I've been thinking about that too. It could be really, really, it's scary, but I'm curious, Sean, have you enjoyed the process? Yeah, very much so. I mean, talk about, you know, I think it's right up your alley, Ben, not that you don't know that already, but just the day-to-day scene work, the dramaturgy of discovering, you know, intense. When you keep going with something, because you never get to do that when you're doing a movie or show. That's exactly right. That you get into, I mean, to performance 100 or 150 and all of a sudden you're having to discover
你在节目上。但我们，你能想象自己做那个吗，本，每周在百老汇演八场戏？你做过。是的，我可以。我做过，虽然是很久以前了。是的。我也一直在考虑这个问题。它可能真的，真的，很吓人，但我很好奇，肖恩，你享受这个过程吗？是的，非常享受。我的意思是，谈论，你知道，我认为这非常适合你，本，并不是你不知道这一点，但只是日常的场景工作，发现的戏剧性，你知道，很强烈。当你坚持做某事时，因为你在拍电影或节目时永远无法做到这一点。完全正确。你进入，我的意思是，到第100场或150场表演时，突然间你不得不去发现
new stuff and it can open up in a way that it never did before. It's really cool. And you discover, and through the rehearsal process, you break down just every word, every sentence, every moment, and it's, and you refine it. It's really cool. And isn't there also a great simplicity to doing theater too, where it's like you live your life, you wake up, you know, you have your routine, you maybe ride your bike to the theater, you know, you have your backpack. I mean, it's simple if you're not a crazy person like I am, which is like I wake up, I'm like, I gotta warm up my, do the voice thing, and then you gotta make sure you drink to it and eat the right thing, and then you gotta go early. Finger exercises for all the piano playing, right?
新的东西，它可以以一种以前从未有过的方式打开。这真的很酷。而且你发现，通过排练过程，你分解每一个词，每一个句子，每一个时刻，然后你提炼它。这真的很酷。而且做戏剧不是也有一种伟大的简单性吗，就像你过你的生活，你醒来，你知道，你有你的日常，你可能骑自行车去剧院，你知道，你有你的背包。我的意思是，如果你不像我这样是个疯子，这很简单，就像我醒来，我就想，我得热身，做发声练习，然后你得确保你喝水并吃正确的东西，然后你得早点去。钢琴演奏的手指练习，对吧？
Are you actually playing the piano? I'm actually playing the Rhapsody in Blue. He's a classically trained pianist. He's doing wow. Yeah, he's incredible. Yeah, well, thanks. And so everything is leading to that performance time, right? Yeah, it's a really cool concept. Doug Wright, who wrote it, it's a true story that Oscar LeVan got a pass from the treatment center that he was in a four hour pass to get out and appear on a game show. For our play, we switched it to tonight's show, because everybody knows that tonight's show. So he's got four hours to appear, then he has to go back to treatment, and it's what happened in that night. And Sean does it every night, and he plays the piano,
你真的在弹钢琴吗？我真的在弹《蓝色狂想曲》。他是一位受过古典训练的钢琴家。他在做，哇。是的，他令人难以置信。是的，嗯，谢谢。所以一切都指向那个表演时间，对吧？是的，这是一个非常酷的概念。写它的道格·赖特，这是一个真实的故事，奥斯卡·勒凡从他所在的治疗中心获得了一张通行证，一张四小时的通行证，可以出去参加一个游戏节目。对于我们的戏，我们把它改成了今夜秀，因为每个人都知道那个今夜秀。所以他有四个小时的时间去参加，然后他必须回到治疗中心，这就是那天晚上发生的事情。肖恩每天晚上都这样做，他弹钢琴，
and he does all these, he's got like 80 monologues, he does this all on a belly of Philly McDonald's every night, right? Will actually ran lines with me on the tour, and he was like, you have to fucking say that. He was, he was, honestly, Ben, I thought like, oh, this is, I just, I would call it and just say, I'm not showing up. I'm sorry. I quit. That's incredible. Speaking of quitting, yes, Spen. Ben, we've taken up, we could do two hours, three hours with you. I love being a part of your show. Your show is awesome. It's, by the way, in our family, it's the one podcast, because we're not a big podcast family, but it's, it's, it's,
他做了所有这些，他有大约80个独白，他每天晚上都在费城麦当劳的肚子上做这一切，对吧？威尔实际上在巡演中和我对台词，他就像，你必须说那个。他，他，老实说，本，我当时想，哦，这是，我只是，我会打电话说，我不去了。对不起。我不干了。这太不可思议了。说到辞职，是的，本。本，我们占用了，我们可以和你聊两个小时，三个小时。我喜欢成为你节目的一部分。你的节目太棒了。顺便说一句，在我们家里，它是唯一的播客，因为我们不是一个大的播客家庭，但它，它，它，
he reached the whole family. My daughter, I think, has listened to every single episode. No way. Aw, that's sweet. The Teller High, please. She's, yeah, big fan. Even Christine, who's not a big podcast listener, really enjoys the show. Teller High, too. But then you're going to say, even Christine, who dislikes Will immensely. Here's how much my daughter likes it. She has no interest in F1, Formula 1 racing. I'm really into it. My son, Clint, is getting into it, too.
他触及了整个家庭。我想我女儿听了每一集。不会吧。噢，那太贴心了。泰勒高，拜托。她，是的，大粉丝。即使是不怎么听播客的克里斯汀，也非常喜欢这个节目。泰勒高，也是。但然后你会说，即使是极其讨厌威尔的克里斯汀。这是我女儿有多喜欢它的程度。她对F1，一级方程式赛车毫无兴趣。我真的很喜欢它。我儿子克林特也开始喜欢它了。
I'm getting into it, too. But she and I were driving from Boston to New York, and we listened to the Daniel Ricardo episode. And she, and she sat through it because she doesn't, cares nothing about F1, but because she loves the show, she listened to it. I thought it was, that was a fascinating episode to hear him talk about. He's a cool dude. I thought it was great because he's so fascinating. But anyway, the show is awesome and happy to be with you guys. We didn't even cover any of the Torrid Love Affair between Tony Wander and Joe Bluth.
我也开始喜欢它了。但她和我开车从波士顿去纽约，我们听了丹尼尔·里卡多的那一集。她，她听完了，因为她不，对F1一点也不关心，但因为她喜欢这个节目，她听了。我觉得那是，那是一集令人着迷的节目，听他谈论。他是个酷家伙。我觉得这很棒，因为他太迷人了。但无论如何，这个节目太棒了，很高兴和你们在一起。我们甚至没有涵盖托尼·万德和乔·布鲁斯之间那段炽热的恋情。
I know, but you guys want to have a private moment. Ben, do you ever have people come up to you and just say, same? Do you remember, Ben? Do you remember how insane that day was when we shot that stuff? We laughed so hard. Ridiculous. It's so much fun. Sean, our characters, our characters on Arrested. Sean's never, Arrested is about, was a show that used to be on the Jason and I and Ben was on, and his wife, Christine, the whole Stiller family was on, you were not on it, and you've never watched it. And this nice episode was Sean. But Ben and our recurring thing over the years was that our characters were competing magicians. And at the very end, it turns out that maybe
我知道，但你们想有一个私人的时刻。本，有没有人走过来对你说，我也是？你还记得吗，本？你还记得我们拍摄那些东西的那天有多疯狂吗？我们笑得太厉害了。荒谬。这太有趣了。肖恩，我们的角色，我们在《发展受阻》里的角色。肖恩从来没有，发展受阻是一个曾经在杰森和我以及本都在的节目，他的妻子克里斯汀，整个斯蒂勒家族都在，你不在里面，而且你从来没看过它。而这个不错的剧集是肖恩的。但本和我们多年来的反复出现的事情是我们的角色是竞争对手的魔术师。而在最后，结果发现也许
they were in love with each other, but maybe neither of them had never really had a friend. So that's why they liked each other. That's hysterical. It was insane. Very ambiguous. Yeah. And we were really connected when we got together. Yeah. Like both in sort of like, yeah, same, same, same. That's really funny. Well, we love you here at Smart List, Ben. We love you, Ben. And hi to the family, and thank you for saying yes to sitting with us for an hour. Great to see you all, and hopefully we'll see each other soon.
他们彼此相爱，但也许他们俩从来没有真正拥有过朋友。所以这就是为什么他们喜欢对方。这太歇斯底里了。这太疯狂了。非常模棱两可。是的。当我们聚在一起时，我们真的很有联系。是的。就像两者都有点像，是的，一样，一样，一样。这真的很有趣。好吧，我们在Smart Less这里爱你，本。我们爱你，本。向家人问好，谢谢你答应和我们坐一个小时。很高兴见到你们所有人，希望我们很快能再见面。
Great to see you too, man. That'd be great. All right, buddy. Talk soon. Bye, guys. Bye, Ben. Bye, Ben. Bye, Ben. Ben Franklin Stiller, unbelievable. He's great. I mean, isn't he? He's one of the most famous comedic actors of our generation. He's done so much. I mean, a little bit of history on him. So many huge comedy. I know. It's nuts.
很高兴见到你，伙计。那太棒了。好的，伙计。回头聊。再见，伙计们。再见，本。再见，本。再见，本。本·富兰克林·斯蒂勒，难以置信。他很棒。我的意思是，不是吗？他是我们这一代最著名的喜剧演员之一。他做了这么多。我的意思是，关于他的一点历史。这么多巨大的喜剧。我知道。这太疯狂了。
If you had done any research at all, Jason, then you would have been here for three hours. Some of the stuff, if just any. But Jason, do you remember that first day when he showed up on Arrested, and we only had him for like two hours because he was in the middle of like eight big movies? Yeah, yeah. And just the whole set, everybody was just a buzz. Ben Stiller wanted to do our show, and we got to do this. We had him for like 12 minutes. This was crazy. I was so glad that I didn't have to work with him. I would have been a nervous wreck.
如果你做了任何研究，杰森，那你就会在这里待三个小时了。有些东西，如果只是任何。但杰森，你还记得他第一次出现在《发展受阻》的那天吗，我们只有他大约两个小时，因为他正忙于八部大电影？是的，是的。整个剧组，每个人都嗡嗡作响。本·斯蒂勒想做我们的节目，我们得做这个。我们只有他大约12分钟。这太疯狂了。我很高兴我不必和他一起工作。我会是一个紧张的残骸。
I was with Tony Hale, I guess, with Buster that first time. I was so nervous. And I met him just a couple of times. He'd done that movie with Amy and Jack. But you used it though, right? I just seem to remember Job sort of like took on this air of like, oh, here's my competition. Like being kind of like all nervous and kind of uptight and aggressive. I was mad at him, but I was also still like, you know. Deeply in love. Yeah. Making faces. Jay, have you had a chance to check out Severance yet? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Oh, it's bitching.
我当时和托尼·黑尔在一起，我想是和巴斯特第一次。我太紧张了。我只见过他几次。他拍过那部和艾米、杰克一起的电影。但你用了它，对吧？我似乎记得乔布有点像带上了这种空气，哦，这是我的竞争对手。就像有点紧张，有点紧绷和咄咄逼人。我对他很生气，但我仍然像，你知道。深深地爱着。是的。做鬼脸。杰伊，你有机会看《人生切割术》了吗？哦，是的。是的。哦，它太棒了。
I haven't. I'm only three, like I said, three episodes in, so please don't say anything. I love this show. I didn't even, no, I won't. But I didn't even, I didn't know he directed it. I watched it. Oh, really? And then I was like, I really, I said to this guy, I was like, God, this is directed so well. I'm not making that up. And we looked it up. I was like, Ben Stiller directed it. That is crazy. I mean, something that specific and that precise, it doesn't just happen. Like there is a really qualified hand at play there.
我还没有。我像我说的那样，只看了三集，所以请不要说什么。我喜欢这个节目。我甚至没有，不，我不会。但我甚至没有，我不知道是他导演的。我看了。哦，真的吗？然后我就像，我真的，我对这个家伙说，我当时想，天哪，这导演得太好了。我不是在编造。然后我们查了一下。我当时想，本·斯蒂勒导演的。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，如此具体和精确的东西，它不会就这样发生。就像那里有一只非常有资格的手在起作用。
You know, you know, well, Jason, you were kind of saying when he sets up the, like shooting the thing, when they do those huge establishing shots of that place where they work and just the way it looks and the tone of the shot, just aesthetically, all of it. And you're like, it's so different and new from what you know of his body of work. And you're like, oh, he's doing something totally new. And then, and I get that he's trying to go genreless. That he's just like, yeah, I'm going to do this now. But he's just basically, I mean, he's, he's listening to his taste, I guess.
你知道，你知道，嗯，杰森，你当时在说当他设置，比如拍摄那个东西时，当他们拍摄那些他们工作的地方的巨大建立镜头时，只是它的外观和镜头的基调，从美学上讲，所有这些。你就像，它和你所知道的他的作品集非常不同和新。你就像，哦，他正在做一些全新的事情。然后，我明白他试图去类型化。他只是像，是的，我现在要这样做。但他基本上，我的意思是，他，他听从他的品味，我想。
And that was my question. Like, how does a guy that comes from what is traditional, you know, like the sketch world doesn't put a big, a big value on, you know, aesthetics and like, you know, focal length on lenses and things like, you know, it is all about, well, just let's just write some funny stuff and make sure the camera's pointed at the person talking. You know, how does he develop that kind of taste and affinity for, you know, the stuff he's doing now? I don't know. But clearly it's a whole other side of him that I don't know. And he's probably inspired by lots of different, you know, he's obviously, he's an incredibly funny comedic actor, then incredibly funny comedic filmmaker,
这就是我的问题。就像，一个来自传统的人，你知道，比如小品世界，不重视美学，你知道，镜头的焦距和事情，你知道，这完全是关于，嗯，让我们写一些有趣的东西，确保摄像机对准说话的人。你知道，他是如何培养那种品味和对，你知道，他现在做的事情的亲和力的？我不知道。但显然这是他我不了解的另一面。他可能受到许多不同的，你知道，他显然，他是一位令人难以置信的有趣的喜剧演员，然后是令人难以置信的有趣的喜剧电影制作人，
because he kind of did those two things simultaneously. And then now he's just going and people are sending him scripts and he's just, and he's just getting inspired by whatever is near. Bye. Near. Wow, that's looking at him out of nowhere from the rear. That's how you do a fucking bi-dix. Unbelievable. Well, I'm going to go think about that one. I hate having to teach so much. You must be exhausted from teaching. I'm teaching and I'm learning. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco,
因为他同时做了那两件事。然后现在他只是去，人们给他发剧本，他只是，他只是被附近的东西所激励。再见。附近。哇，那是从后面突然看着他。这就是你做一个该死的双向的方式。难以置信。好吧，我要去想那个。我讨厌不得不教这么多。你一定教得很累。我在教，我在学。Smart Less。Smart Less。Smart Less是100%有机的，由Rob Armjolf，Bennett Barbaco，
and Michael Grant Terry. Smart. Less. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和Michael Grant Terry手工制作。Smart Less。我们的下一集将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus提前且无广告地收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。